greetings ball sniffers this podcast is
brought to you by i hate my boss the
newest podcast from wondering need
workplace advice go listen to i hate my
boss and subscribe to it when wherever
you listen to this podcast this podcast
is also brought to you by naturebox
what do you want when you want a snack
but all you can find is junk food rely
on your self-control to resist the
temptation
please you eat that junk food start
snacking healthy with naturebox right
now natureopbox is offering our family
50 off your first order when you go to
naturebox.com
also the days are back
it's time to wash that muffler go to
hellotushy.com right now and get 10 off
your portable bidet never again will
your [ __ ] stink like 10 dead [ __ ]
savages you understand me
hit it lee
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here
monday night
we have a special guest tonight my
brother mr joe rogan we're going to talk
about this [ __ ] united thing holla
joey and i were talking about how bad
flying was this weekend in buffalo it
was bad bruce buffer's flight got
canceled because they didn't have a
pilot everybody's on the plane they're
like sorry we don't have a pilot
everybody has to get off and then the
flight was just canceled no pilot
our flight got cancelled because the the
tires didn't have any air in them and
they had to fly tires there we're
supposed to leave at 8 30 in the morning
didn't wind up leaving until we took off
we hopped on a jet blue to new york and
then caught a flight from new york
um we were supposed to fly into chicago
and uh they they it would change from 8
30 in the morning they kept moving it up
and up because i get notifications on my
phone and it they moved it up to 4 30
p.m and it didn't even take off then it
took off sometime after 5 p.m
it was hard i don't know i don't blame
it i know [ __ ] snow storm they were
slipping how the [ __ ] don't they retire
how the [ __ ] doesn't your pilot show up
how the [ __ ] doesn't you know it's just
too many coincidences buffalo's just not
a good airport there's just not a lot of
people flying in there they're not
prepared they're not equipped i went to
vermont a couple years ago and they just
canceled the flight the night before
there was no weather they just i don't
think they had enough people flying out
of burlington vermont the next day
that's probably exactly what it was
yeah so we're going to watch this thing
on united where a passenger apparently
had a ticket was in his seat
and they wanted to get a crew member who
remembers it was like three or four crew
members they had to get people off the
flight [ __ ] so people who had tickets
who paid for tickets were going
somewhere and they told this guy they
just randomly picked people they told
this guy you got to get up you didn't
want to get up so they dragged them off
check this out it's gonna it's gonna
piss you off and imagine this is you
united's been slipping anyway look at
this
come on come on
united airlines overbooked the flight
they randomly selected people to kick
off so their standby crew could have a
seat let's see if i can find a better
version of it
there's a few of them
the man was chosen at random but he
refused to leave his seat
oh my god oh my god oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
that's crazy
remind me my husband never use united
airlines when we fly the situation could
have been handled better than that yeah
all these people are freaking out and
the more people find out about this over
today and over the rest of the week
united's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ]
i just can't believe they did that to
the guy they forcibly removed him
for why do they think they could do that
here's the statement pause that for a
second flight 3411 from chicago to
louisville was overbooked after our team
looked for volunteers one customer
refused to leave the aircraft
voluntarily
okay look what they just said after they
look for
volunteers one customer refused to leave
the aircraft voluntarily you look for
volunteers the guy's not a volunteer
that's not refusing to leave voluntarily
that's a nice way of saying you took a
customer and you [ __ ] assaulted them
and law enforcement was asked to come to
the gate
keep going because it keeps going
pause it because their statement
continues it's getting really bad
see the rest of it we apologize for the
overbook situation no there's more you
backed you went a little too far
no no that's it that's it oh my god
that's it we apologize for the overbook
situation further details on the removed
customer should be directed to
authorities how about [ __ ] you
i can't believe they would take a
customer
and just do that
to get uh crew members too it wasn't
like they were trying to get like other
customers they had both too many
customers
from when i read it was just they had to
get crew members to whatever city that
was yeah you they can't do that you
can't do that
people should start boycotting them let
me tell you something united has blown
for years i took him into newark one
time no [ __ ] tv no [ __ ] shitty
food
first class was like [ __ ] garbage
into newark that's why i don't i don't
fly into newark no more
you know uh i love whatever virgin but
then it can't get me back from newark so
i'm gonna end up at kennedy anyway yeah
so new york's not a good airport
you know i don't use the [ __ ] about it
arie used to [ __ ] about it constantly
[ __ ] newark [ __ ] newark you know what my
life's a lot easier believe it or not
when i land in jfk yeah it really is
smooth worst case scenario you go to
[ __ ] the palms and get a steak and
eggs yeah like a gentleman in the bloody
mary and you sit it up there's tons of
entertainment at kennedy oh yeah you get
a massage you get your feet rubbed they
got [ __ ] everything at kennedy
dog we i'm i didn't i thought you flew
out okay
it was horrible
it was horrible
i'm like you i waited for 10 minutes i
had already a book three o'clock but i
got it at 7 41 and i didn't trust it
yeah i went to southwest was empty
everybody was there when i got there was
kids at the airport all going to [ __ ]
uh spring break
i went to united they had nothing i went
the delta delta was done
and i went to the other one
jetblue and jetblue was done until
tomorrow until sunday
i was like you know what i got my 340 i
take my chances yeah before i left the
hotel i called and they go the plane
that you're going from l.a is already in
chicago you landed from room
this morning it's already ready to go
it's on time
and the other one was on time and you
know what everything was smooth knock on
wood took me 25 minutes up to four or
five to get home on sunday it was empty
yeah that you have options in other
places but if you fly to a place like
buffalo there's not a lot of options you
know it's like if you're flying out of
bozeman montana or something like that
like
good luck listen bro i can't get a
direct ticket from milwaukee to detroit
the flight the flight is longer from
milwaukee to detroit than what it is
from [ __ ] lax to [ __ ]
milwaukee really how the [ __ ] did that
happen
i gotta fly into chicago it's a tough
business the the business of uh selling
airline tickets and flying people around
you've got to make money not really well
you got to think who the [ __ ] flying
in and out of buffalo so in order for
them to have pac what's there right
other than the ufc like when you have a
big event or a football game or
something like that if there's not that
a lot of people connect to go to canada
a lot of people fly to buffalo those
planes are always pretty [ __ ] the
airport was empty
my at three o'clock the airport was
completely empty when i walked in
everybody flew out earlier and i'll tell
you what when i landed lax
empty lax was empty empty i couldn't
[ __ ] believe it i've never seen it
like that i was like wait a second no
one could get back in have you guys ever
have you guys boycotted an airline
because like it's weird you can't they
have you over a barrel you can get as
mad as you want them but some airlines
only fly certain places and they're the
cheaper ones so you gotta fly them
sometimes i bet a lot of people are
gonna boycott united after that
yeah but until the next vacation like
not many be like you guys fly a lot more
than most people fly yeah i think when
most people fly it's just whatever
airlines cheapest yeah but if people
have an option now i think they're gonna
choose my first choice is always
american i know where i'm going yeah
i know where i'm going if i go to new
york i'm only going delta or the other
one america sinks your boat virgin's
great but they're going away virgin's
not going to be around anymore where are
they going they're merging with somebody
alaska a lot for some weird like i don't
know why
i took i took alaska airlines that was
the only direct flight into baltimore
was alaska [ __ ] airlines a red-eye
they do all right alaska does all right
and they fly me to portland from burbank
yeah they're good to seattle too really
yeah yeah no no tremendous not bad
so that's the end of virgin i'm i'm
telling you
i'm telling you the leader right now is
that mint and i know you i know the type
of guy you are yeah i know the type of
guy you are
they got a door
they got the
there's a latch right here that closes
your door so you go for the door goes ah
like a batman movie it just closes real
fast
when they bring you the food they press
the latch and the door opens and that's
how she gives you the food like prisoner
44.
i don't even know what you're saying i
don't even know what it looks like i put
the sleep apnea machine right here i
think it's like a pod like those
internationals
let's see if you can find that jet blue
jack blue i like delta to kennedy it's
very nice
very nice they got the lay down bed and
[ __ ] i'm getting real tired of flying i
know i'd like to do a residency in los
angeles
everybody goes to vegas to do a
residency how many [ __ ] people are
there in la you could sell out la every
weekend if you had a club like just a
club playa del carmen
down there get away down there right by
the airport where's playa del carmen by
our friend that's where he has the
his uh brendan has the office down there
nice and clean down there joe rogan
that's a good spot but anywhere down by
the ocean takes forever to drive that's
what it looks like the pod let me cheat
let me see this thing let me see a
close-up oh that's nice that's jetblue
yeah i'm dog is this a new thing yeah
how many of these they have they have uh
you can only go from here to boston or
here
to uh jk jfk so the whole plane is
filled with these things no the front
row it's like eight rows but you get a
an even number and you're by yourself in
the so it's like essentially like first
class
so they're doing first class
there you go that's by yourself
that's by yourself they see that little
box they give you they give you a thing
to cover your eyes they give you a
blanket they give you a pillow
the bottled water is behind your left
arm
you can't even [ __ ] see it you know
almost no and it's got a statue you can
put your bottled water right in there
you got movies i saw the godfather too
on the way there
that's the refrigerator and the cheap
seats yeah your refrigerator yeah you
just get up and help your [ __ ] self
this is for everybody yeah this is for
everybody yes
that's so mid-flight you don't have to
bother nobody you get up you get your
[ __ ] soda these people are getting
it's 2017. wow but those front rows i'm
telling your dog
tremendous i was blown the [ __ ] away
that's just like first class and that
goes to kennedy coast to kennedy but not
from burbank me and boss rooting had
this conversation because box was like
you got to get on mint i go ah burbank
there's no
mint because it's a small airport right
so the bigger plane can't land on that
oh is that what it is yeah oh that makes
sense
that makes sense i always wondered why
there's nothing they don't land in
newark either
nothing that a burbank does
two small flights no small flights
no jet blue doesn't fly at the [ __ ]
door oh
uh well you don't want to fly in newark
even if i land even if i work in new
jersey i usually don't fly in new york i
fly in new york have you ever flown to
atlantic city
yes when i did the ufc there i did
from right from here i think i don't
remember so long i got it so long ago i
did the borgata did you do the bargain
with me yes
it's one of the few places like the borg
is one of the few places and henzo
gracie showed up too remember yeah he
was howling at your [ __ ] that's right
that was crazy i remember enzo gracie is
a [ __ ] maniac he thought all you he
was like the dirtier the crazier you got
the more he was like
he was [ __ ] flopping around in his
seat laughing
i always walk past that place i'm scared
to walk in tenzo's yeah in new york
those are killers they are killers but
they're super nice guys it's a horror
show you'll get tapped out but they'll
be nice to you oh my god that's just how
it goes
yeah i'm scared of those new york
schools i always make plans yeah i'm
gonna go over there after norton show
and show up yeah [ __ ] you he's a great
guy though i get in that goddamn uber
and i shoot right back to that fairy
jack yeah and i don't look back
[ __ ] you they'll kill you do you think
you could ever live in manhattan
we had this discussion with uh somebody
a few weeks ago and they showed the rent
of where i grew up on 88th street and i
nearly shipped my pants oh it's insane
the same place where i grew up now i
think it was what was a seven grand for
a one bedroom
that's not even uh outrageous yeah
the the the money there so crazy it
makes you wonder how anyone can afford
to live there other than like really
wealthy people
if there's any city that gives me
anxiety it's new york city at night
anymore yeah i've gotten to the age that
i've gotten very comfortable here
and when i go play the stand on thursday
nights i stand on the corner before you
go in
and i actually [ __ ] can't take the
cars anymore like the speed that that
electricity i'm not used to anymore
really yeah it [ __ ] with me a little
bit so on thursdays i don't go into the
city no more i just wait till i go to
the shows and i
you know it's weird how you
when you're from that area it takes you
a couple days to acclimate like i was
getting on the ferry and i was getting
bullied
on the ferry you yeah getting bullied
straight up people walked in front of me
and [ __ ] but i'm from l.a i don't need
this aggravation
these days they were doing that oh
they're [ __ ] rude [ __ ] the
people who live on the jersey side and
they work in new york they think their
[ __ ] don't stink so they cut you off you
know and you overcome it because you're
an adult and you don't give a [ __ ]
by saturday
some lady pregnant with a [ __ ] thing
was trying to cut me off and i finally
go oh
relax
like you forget that you're a nice
person like you forget
wow people not opening up doors like
people pushing you're like you know what
i'm from a different civilization you
know like people
you forget and then you toughen up by
saturday but then you'll leave on sunday
anyway so what's the toughness for you
know what i've been saying for a while
is that what's going on in new york and
what goes on the entire east coast with
the difference between the way people
behave there versus out here is that
they're still too close to the people
that first landed there like the people
that first landed there like my
grandparents and their families
they came over from
europe italy and ireland and everything
like that those were barbarians those
people are animals i mean you just think
about life
like you're talking about the depression
right this is all uh my grandparents
came like when the depression was going
on
they i mean it was a hard hard world
people were tough and they were mean and
you got [ __ ] with and you know my
grandfather used to tell me horror
stories about getting bullied and they
call him a guinea [ __ ]
like and and just mean [ __ ] and beating
him up and just everybody was mean
today yeah yeah that's how you have to
look at the heart of the world
if it was today trump would ban [ __ ]
travel in italy yeah probably you know
no i saw that documentary and it was the
most interesting thing i ever saw
and it really taught me a lot about that
culture i grew up around because it
always seemed very interesting to me
hbo did a two-part special on sinatra
and the first part they discussed his
childhood in hoboken and how at that
time the irish were the oppressor
you press her the oppressor so the
guineas weren't allowed past ninth
street really which really [ __ ] with
them
then
stuff happened and the italians you know
grew and then they got past 9th street
but sinatra always had that mentality
of i was never allowed over 9th street
you got to watch it it's [ __ ]
interesting plus i understood the people
i grew up with from north america and
see
hoboken is moving on up to north bergen
we're going to house up in north bergen
we've got a front yard you know i'm
saying like half of the people i grew up
with their roots are hoboken
so when i watched that special north
virgin was better north bergen was more
residential the way hoboken was more you
know tournaments and three floors and
you know yeah north bergen once they
built north berlin a lot of people moved
to north bergen there used to be a club
there used to be a club in hoboken what
was it it was a stand-up club there
i don't i remember i was long gone by
they still do stand up there danny
aiello has a room on tuesday nights
uh they've been really trying like over
the years to do stand up i did a benefit
for the whole broken police department
oh yeah oh a long time ago i did it i
did the club there in like 91 or 92 or
something like that and they had
pictures all over the wall the time
eddie murphy stopped by and so i
remember like eddie murphy was here one
point time like you know they had like a
photo and it said you know like
1989 eddie murphy you know it was like
three years ago and i was like oh
remember that time three years ago eddie
murphy came down there [ __ ] i didn't
know it was a comedy club in hoboken
when i started i started in denver when
i went back
the big club was rascals and the other
one but there was also main street
showcase
it was i i it was always it was
i saw bill bellamy on the plane one time
and i was talking to him about it uh he
goes yeah that was my roots main street
showcase bill bellamy i forgot him
all those guys were from that part of
new jersey and when the farming team
came in here
him and no norton are from like south
jersey middle new jersey they moved to
northern new jersey an apartment
and they were all jersey guys
like they're jersey guys i'm saying
don't take them seriously yeah right he
was saying that nobody took it seriously
yeah norton always had that it like
bothered him
you're not funny till you moved to new
york yeah isn't that funny like you have
to go to new york to be taken seriously
if you live in new jersey or just a hack
you're telling fart jokes and [ __ ] you
know
those clubs in jersey are brutal
i mean bananas is is club the one that's
little and it's brutal you do comedy on
the ping-pong table
did you want a poughkeepsie i did the
one in poughkeepsie i did that one a
couple times that's
in a ballroom way yeah and the next it's
next to a gas station that's as good as
it gets dog and they put you in the
downstairs room and when i tell you it's
[ __ ] freezing
it's [ __ ] freezing they got one diner
in the lobby and it's the worst food
you've ever eaten in your life even if
they give you the 30 off you rather
[ __ ] started that
that's how bad that place is and you're
stuck up there for two [ __ ] nights
next to a gas station
that's it i worked up there with tony v
do you know tony v [ __ ] yeah i worked up
there with tony v i was the middle he
was the headliner and some lady kept
flashing the light while i was on stage
i was supposed to like i don't know 20
25 minutes something like that
like 10 or 15 she's flashed online
uh and i did i ignored it i just did my
set i got off stage and she goes okay i
don't know if you know how we do it here
but you can't do that language at this
club
and i remember saying like what are you
talking about i was i was smiles
laughing so i was already moved in new
york i was already like i was already
getting work i already had sussman as a
manager i was like what
and she was like you're going to have to
change your act to work oh no i'm not i
go what are you the manager here i go i
got booked here i got booked here by the
owner of the club i'm going to do my act
they know what my act is
you don't like it so you want me to
change
and like she looked at me and you know
like she didn't expect that
and i just raised my eyebrows and i just
walked away
and i just finished out the weekend and
she never spoke a [ __ ] word to me
again she didn't say hi she didn't look
at me ain't that great when you have the
[ __ ] once i yeah once everyone saw
you gotta drop a bomb on a [ __ ]
and they'll just look at you like what
she was talking to me like she was the
manager at wendy's and i was the fry boy
she's like i don't know if you know how
this works here you know like she's like
the lady that takes the tickets
you know those the clubs are all in a
hotel you know like bananas was in a
hotel right yeah both of them both of
them so she just decided she didn't like
my act you know because i talked about
sex so she's just decided that i was
gonna have to change my act i don't know
i'll just i'll never forget her face i
don't know if you know how we do it here
but you you can't do with that language
here oh [ __ ] the race let me tell you
something it's amazing those people i
did the week one time i was dumb enough
to take a week because i was a coked out
[ __ ] savage
at the houston little club the little
club the little club on the south side
oh that's the one that ralphie used to
do yes yeah so they put you up in a
hotel in the middle of nowhere right
it's like it's out there if somebody
else took it over now they sold it and
somebody else took it over that club was
there for a long time
they got a different type of audience
than wes gray let's just say it was
completely different than the last stop
so it's like right once i went there one
sunday night and the owner was there and
i did my set
and he goes when do you want to get
booked and i go you know i called pete i
go pete you money because nah nah take
the week i took the thursday friday and
saturday so i get to do the thursday
night he's not there the wife is there
so the same thing [ __ ] happened right
before i go on stage and at that time i
wasn't
my head wasn't in it like that she came
up to me she's like listen
i heard rumors not here here we work
spotless clean
if you say one bad thing you're fired
oh those [ __ ] people well guess what
i [ __ ] my pants i really did for the
first 15 i tried i struggled i was
eating
death and then i just let loose and they
went [ __ ] bananas
i said [ __ ] it i'll just take the 200
for the night i don't give a [ __ ]
i walked off she didn't talk to me
the next night i came in the husband was
there i pulled him aside like oh she
didn't [ __ ] know she goes ah i
explained to her last night what
happened i'm sorry danny that was his
name
i'm sorry blah blah blah i go up there
and right there it was one of those
clubs where right here is the stage and
people actually take their drinks and
they're looking at me like this
and 20 minutes into my [ __ ] show i'm
looking at this couple and i'm looking
at her and she's [ __ ] up john rogan
she's [ __ ] up and i'm like oh jesus
christ
and finally i keep checking out like
every eight minutes and she's getting
deeper and deeper she's closing one eye
once they close the one eye they're
[ __ ] up
and finally i swear i'll go like this
and she covers her log
no no no no the puke starts shooting on
every box
like a [ __ ] what's that thing the
kids playing like a like a sprinkler but
just awkward chunks and then she just
let it all out and she sat there for
five minutes puke all over this stuff
bro nobody paid everybody got up like
somebody was shooting he thought
terrorists were shooting in the club
everybody got up and started running for
the [ __ ] door they had to stop people
she had a puddle of barf around her the
boyfriend left her there
the boyfriend just got up and walked out
if he didn't know nothing
you didn't see me with me give me back
my credit card
i never went back there again once
somebody pukes on stage i can't i can't
hang out with you no more it's amazing
like the bad advice they give you early
on in your stand-up career i want to
shoot them while
you can't make it if you're dirty like
they tell you can't make it i mean i i
can't remember how many times i heard
that
what is a [ __ ] pipe holy [ __ ]
somebody gave me cleavage that's the
savage stuff we only let him out for
special occasions he's amazing
do the people at home see this thing oh
that thing is [ __ ] tremendous oh this
is who did this work you know somebody
in cleveland there's a whole uh industry
like a whole art form now the glass pipe
art form industry i mean it's there's
amazing artists that are just doing a
glass heart i got another one at the
house some kid gave me that i don't even
want to smoke out it's so beautiful
incredible i need a picture that's the
savage that's the original right there
he's missing the tooth
he don't give a [ __ ]
what kind of advice do they give you for
someone puking on you when you're on
stage doesn't say no
they can't give you advice for that
there was no advice
i walked off the stage and knew i wasn't
going to be ever there ever again you
understand me that's what i knew for
sure
look at me
there's some places you [ __ ] go and
you know you're never going to go back
there they would just tell you like they
would give you advice when you're young
you start now like say if you're a young
guy and you were pulled you over there
ever let me know the people everybody
everybody that you look at today i don't
want to say their names they never made
it
that they never made the one guy that
did make it that would have already made
it at the time who gave me the opposite
advice was lenny clark it's funny
because his brother mike was a booking
agent who's a great guy mike clark that
guy paid my rent [ __ ] many many many
many times with his gigs because he was
one of the guys that he had a lot of
satellite rooms he had giggles and
saugus on route 1
and
he had a few uh outside rooms and he
would book his brother lenny and lenny
was on hbo he had done rodney
dangerfield special lenny was a big
comic he had done a bunch of movies like
lenny was big and this is before lenny's
sitcom and when he had that sitcom
and i opened up for lenny's at jays in
pittsfield massachusetts it was in
western massachusetts it was way out
there like two and a half three hours
away from boston
and uh people loved it there because it
was a real stage and they had real
comedy there like they had lenny clark
when lenny clark was big
and i went up and i opened up for lenny
it was the second paid gig i ever got in
my life
and i got off stage and mike clark said
body you're [ __ ] funny but i can't
book you you're too dirty and he goes
that bit you do about madonna you can't
do that it's like it's funny but i know
you gotta clean it up you gotta clean it
up
and uh so lenny comes off stage right
after his brother gives me advice lenny
goes outside he goes kid you are [ __ ]
hilarious he goes don't change a thing
holy [ __ ] that madonna bit had me
laughing my balls off and he goes lenny
i just told him to stop doing that bit
he goes oh yeah yeah yeah you should
probably stop doing it it's going to be
hard to get work but [ __ ] kid you're
funny and uh it was like good advice and
bad advice and i listened to lenny i was
like you know his brother's a great guy
and everything like that but lenny is
lenny clark so they have lenny clark
tell you you're funny i was like wow
that was huge for me
but his brother was giving me bad advice
he's like but he wanted me to work you
know it was like but that was the thing
back then it was in 1989 or 1988.
back then you couldn't work if you were
dirty like there was no work everybody
wanted to get on the tonight show no
there was a few hbo specials that had
been given out like the kennison and a
few other people but
you had to be somebody to get those if
you wanted to be dirty you had to be
somebody already so what it was was a
lot of these guys were you know quote
unquote dirty they would have clean sets
that they would do on the tonight show
or letterman or whatever and then they
would have a few dirty bits that they
would reserve for a nightclub and they
would close with those bits so if they
ever did an atrial special that's when
they would do those
i knew i had to be dirty three years
like i was just lying to myself
people come up here with that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and i gave this new york try i tried it
i tried it but it just didn't work out
for me i don't i'm not gonna ask you to
do a joke but like what was a clean
premise for you i really know a clean
premise for you to be honest that's old
weed
all right a clean premise in those days
was
oh jesus christ a clean premise
hold on
a clean premise in those days was a
godzilla
what would godzilla do oh you gotta look
at this thing you guys are advanced here
what would godzilla do
if he came back into the hudson
you know it was terrible
it was terrible it was brutally terrible
i had a thing about a
a ship going into the hudson
i had a thing about speakers you could
put them back in the windows because
bows some electric it was just a horror
machine
it was a [ __ ] horror show
you know i can't i can't imagine you
making electronic jokes joey used to try
to be clean in the early days when i
first saw him it was a nightmare joey
was um trying to deal with um agents and
managers when you first moved to l.a oh
my god we first became friends yeah you
were you were dealing with honestly
and one day you go you know what it
really doesn't matter
it really doesn't matter it really
doesn't matter as long as you're you how
did you figure it out because i've
always wondered that because you you
figured it out and there was like a big
turn around like one day you just
stopped giving a [ __ ]
it was weird it was like a a it was a a
an event it was a series of events
it was that i wasn't
dating that dirty you got a lighter over
there
i wasn't dating that dirty [ __ ] anymore
that clears your mind at 30 percent
i had let go a lot of [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] scaring the [ __ ] out of me in la
and that's 60 percent of your problem
right there
everybody who had me locked in
bullshitting me that you needed to do
this and need to do that
and you you know and all of a sudden i'm
watching you and i'm watching these guys
the
the clean
but they make me laugh but they're not
making me laugh like the guys that are
real yeah that took a different [ __ ]
animal you know i remember us having
conversations about it yeah when you
were like ah you could go do that i
gotta i gotta you know there's people
watching me yeah no no it was scary it
was scary there for no reason
yeah it was just the [ __ ] that they
put into your head that you can't you
can't well there was no reason but
it was holding you back absolutely
because people could see when you're
faking the funk well not just that like
even once you started killing it was
still holding you back like there was
still a lot of agents and managers that
had a bad opinion of you oh listen
they're gonna
they're gonna say whatever you want to
say but until you deliver the good
that's exactly i figured out i was
talking to tommy easter today
and i go tommy easter let me tell you
something you could be the funniest guy
in this town
you go in the comedy store every night
and [ __ ] destroy that room even
though they're going to see dane cook
eliza schlesinger it doesn't matter you
could destroy that room
nothing matters in this business
just like the mafia to use the size of
the envelope on friday
that's when they pay attention to you
that's when all those naysayers
they eat their words
and they jump on the ship with you well
what's interesting is those people are
are almost useless now useless young
comic it's it's it's
this has changed yeah this has changed
and let me tell you something i know you
hate this talk but this is the reality
of it because you're an intelligent guy
in 2007 there was a writer strike and
these [ __ ] played games for six
or seven months and reality tv crept in
there's about to be another might
writer's strike may 7
these [ __ ] play games the
internet
is gonna [ __ ] them up well where it's
not gonna [ __ ] them up is things like
game of thrones or things like house of
cards like things where you need a lot
of money to shoot them well listen let
me tell you something when the going
gets rough
you put together one of these late night
shows
with brendan and eddie lighting himself
on fire or whatever from eight to eleven
and put a band behind you
people gonna watch your dog
the internet's gonna change the [ __ ]
game if these [ __ ] [ __ ] around
on tv
if these [ __ ] don't settle this
and this goes on like the one in 2007.
you think periscope didn't see this
coming and all these [ __ ] companies
didn't see this coming yeah but don't
you think the writers probably have a
point like all the writers always have a
point no they're not them there's
nothing right writers always have a
point
but listen it's 2017 [ __ ]
he will hesitate masturbate
this [ __ ] machine over here has been
growing since you turned me on to it
it's nothing but a wealth of information
and growth that machine and more people
turn to that you know i don't i don't do
this i don't do this because i'm an
idiot but people watch movies on their
phones
yeah watching the ufc and they're
[ __ ] yeah it's on planes and
my friend yeah don't watch anything on
there content is endless now
content is endless
you don't need cable or tv no more you
got a phone if you're broke if you're a
broke string you got an iphone
and you're trying to work things out in
your life you don't need you could
stream showtime
you could stream hbo
you could stream ifc and you can see
almost everything everything youtube
just came out with a uh like everyone's
coming out with an online cable service
or tv service but youtube's is is the
best one out there for so far it's 30
bucks a month
and you get you get i don't you don't
get every channel but you get a ton of 8
you get a ton of dvr so it's starting to
be where you don't even need anything
let them [ __ ] around keep [ __ ] around
keep it up he's gonna figure this out
and go wait a second i got a good idea
for this
i got a good idea for that two cameras
two gopros and periscope
and a drummer
and you got yourself entertainment jack
for whoever people watch it people at
home craving this our audience is not
from seven to ten no more like it was 20
years ago sorry
it's people from seven to five it's i.t
people
it's people working gas stations people
working construction with earphones on
it's [ __ ] amazing the the loaders at
the airp planes they waved the other day
i'm trying to get on the [ __ ] plane
they waved a couple weeks ago
yeah it's weird right it's very weird so
it's gone to a different [ __ ] level
now
this is what we're doing is growing
every month well no one would ever allow
you to do this no there's nothing
there's no there's no executive in this
town that would have ever said here's
what you need to do joey no they would
have a camera pointed at you you start
smoking pot and just talk [ __ ] nobody
believed you nobody would believe you
and it's that easy it's that [ __ ]
easy it is for you no it's not that easy
for everybody well they listen man but
it's a shot you have a shot with this
when marin first went to his management
and said he was starting to pack as they
laughed at him yeah
that's the reality of it you know yeah
this is something that they didn't know
was coming they're going they're sitting
having meetings right now what are we
going to do
how are we going to get a piece of this
act well i know that some podcasts are
sag you know that right they have those
acting podcasts really
how do they do that
we read a play
no [ __ ] yeah they have series oh well
series is huge huge huge i i firmly
believe that the future of entertainment
is audio i honestly do because
the it gives you so much more
uh ex you're so much more accessible to
them like that you can how you have them
for the drive you have them throughout
the workday and then even at home
how many people do you see when they're
watching tv just playing on their phones
throughout the entire episode and they
they're absorbing what's happening
through audio i honestly think there's
going to be a lot i've always loved
audio oh it's perfect i think people
don't listen enough i love audio i grew
up on richard pryor albums
we grew up listening we have specials
i grew up listening to george carlin i
grew up listening to i didn't watch
[ __ ] freddy prince on tv with a
special how many specials did we see
later on delirious rodney's young
comedians but that came later on
well there's definitely a good market
for audio but there's always going to be
a market for people watching things too
and if you're talking about people that
are sitting down with their phones while
they're watching a tv show like that's
so silly people that do that are so
silly you're playing with your phone
while you're watching the walking dead
or something like that it's so dumb i
think they're i i hate it
it's just people are super super
distracted and childish with the way
they look at things if you're doing that
unless it's a bad show or unless you're
like watching a talk show or something
like that but it just seems to me that
like if you're gonna watch a really good
show you should put the [ __ ] phone
down and sit down and watch that thing
you know if you're gonna watch like
house of cards you ever watched that
kevin spacey show that's a [ __ ] great
show but there's a lot of really good
shows and i think i don't think audio is
the future of entertainment i think it
has a future as a future but it's not
the future because there's always going
to be people that want to see things oh
i'm not saying videos going away
obviously video is great
but when when the name of the game is
advertisers and advertising money that's
like the end goal for all of this
if you're losing people
for eight hours a day like i i think
what's great about these podcasts is the
people like middle class and little are
really listening to it there are higher
level people doing it but if you can't
listen during the day you're probably a
little bit out of the loop podcast wise
you would think
so if you can't watch video during the
day you you don't have all those ads i
just think there's going to be a lot
more of that scripted podcast reality
pod i think there's going to be
everything because
you have so much more access you have a
lot of possibilities how many people do
you think are really listening
throughout the day
that's all i did when i came here that's
how i found joey threw your apartment i
was listening all day at my job right
but isn't that unusual to have a job
that allows you to do that how how usual
is that
when you go on a plane there's people
watching a movie what are your phones on
okay in today's market people have an
assignment or have they have to type a
report they have you on
they're not watching you on youtube but
they're listening to you they're
listening to bill bird listen to mpr
they're listening to the comedy
essential podcast they're listening they
have 40 [ __ ] hours to kill on that
[ __ ] computer gaining hemorrhoids by
the day
you know what i'm saying they listen to
two podcasts they get up they go for a
walk they smoke a cigarette they drink a
cup of coffee they come back they do a
little work to listen to another podcast
you know if you're a night security guy
you work [ __ ] uh
you know all those hours at night you're
lonely in the car sitting there that's
what you listen so if we reach an hour
and a half a piece two hours
you got a lot of time at night to listen
to podcasts we're the kings of the third
crew joe rogan yeah right we are the
kings of the third crew people that work
midnight to eight whether they're in
australia china new jersey california
that's who listens to this while they're
stocking [ __ ]
trucks uh you know
[ __ ] product at a supermarket you
were at a supermarket at two in the
morning and the guys are stuck and they
got earphones on with the black gloves
and they're putting ice cream in the
cases
they listen to everything
to jim norton's podcast listen to opie
and jimmy you know whatever [ __ ] jimmy
and whatever
they listen to the dude that used to be
on it it's amazing how much of a catalog
they have to choose from the first guy
who ever recognized me was a sign
spinner by my my by my job
i was walking across the street he was
he was spinning he he went to the ice
house a couple of times i think he was
going to try to be a comic but yeah
funny yeah ice spinner would be the
perfect guy that's hilarious this has
gone to places where
it's you know you look at your
map at the end of the month and you see
where the people are listening to this
across the world wow and you go what the
[ __ ]
you know like when army said he went to
china
he said 200 people showed up and they
all listen to the podcast they're
working for somebody over there apple
they work for probably something like
that there
that's over in china right
yeah that's where they make the phones
but
okay that's the place as the nets keep
people from jumping off the roof do you
know about that place yeah yeah but how
many people actually jumped
enough that they made nets it wasn't
just one guy
when you when you put them outside
building the cell phone makes you do
this
they live there
they live there they work there they
have dorms they stay in the dorms they
work all day it's scary i mean it's it's
a step above being a slave and people
tell you it's a lot better
than um what they used to have because
they didn't have any opportunity
and this is just how industry works
the way people describe it
they're trying to justify it they say
this is just how industry works industry
works you come into an incredibly deeply
impoverished area you provide them with
a way out like something or a better way
and so that better way of working 16
hours a day people could argue yeah
they're working 16 a day for a dollar a
day yeah or whatever the wage they get
which is substantially lower than
whatever they make here i might be
exaggerating you could probably google
it like how much does a foxconn employee
get per hour
but
they say that
that's how they're able to make these
phones because they can make them in
these factories where people don't get
paid as much but
there's a bunch of people that jump off
the roof
like they have to put fences nets all
around the roof they have nets to catch
people like it's bananas and when they
talk about it you know what they say
they say there's so many employees at
work there's like a half million
employees and the suicides are directly
proportional to how many if that was
like a population of a city that makes
sense that that amount of people always
kill themselves
but they don't do it at work
and they live there
how many is it it's uh the article i
found was a little old but it was it was
like twelve dollars a day you're gonna
get like 400 a month
wow
that's dark
there was some dude last night on 60
minutes
pretty interesting there was two dudes
the guy who
invented the greek yogurt yeah
he was he needed seven hundred thousand
dollars and he saw a factory open up in
new york and
he went to these people and he borrowed
the money he bought the what's the hot
greek yogurt now i don't know
i know you're talking about talking
about tremendous that he had to buy a
plant in twin falls idaho
and he hired what he hires is his
refugees
he gives them jobs and people got pissed
off at him
and they call him this guy donated 10
percent of his factory to his employees
like they get 10 of the earnings every
month from the company they break it up
almost like like company sharing and all
this [ __ ] it was pretty interesting that
story was interesting and there was
another one about a guy
who's saying that these phones are
programmed to program you
huh you're going to watch this
[ __ ] uncle joey out of town
this guy's saying that the industry is
pro they're programming you
through computers and through the phone
this explanation
you gotta hear it
when you get a minute it was on last
night can you find out how much an
iphone would cost if they made it in the
united states
i can google it yeah
google that just out of curiosity so how
much would an iphone cost
there now well the what they cost now i
think in new york dollars a day they get
paid i think a new iphone if you buy it
in america is like a thousand dollars
somewhere in that range
yeah but you know the
a cell phone company subsidizes it
retail it's a thousand you get it for
200 because sprint
wants you to they will they subsidize it
or you they um not subsidize it what's
the word i'm looking for they um
they make like a lease and they put it
over the term
of the uh contract so they spread out
the amount of money that you're getting
paid or that you're paying for the phone
so if you're gonna pay 600 bucks for the
phone they spread it out over three
years so you have a three-year contract
so like you can get it for like 200 off
and so it looks great it looks great but
it's just factored into your monthly
bill right and then you have them for
like three years i tried to pay the
phone they were like no they gave me a
good time yeah they don't want to do
that they don't want to do that they
don't want to do that it's probably
more valuable to them and then also you
can't leave
i guess if you can leave if you have
like a phone that is uh what's the word
what without uh
jailbroken
no no i don't think it's that i think
it's unlocked
jailbroken is when you uh you get into
it and you can [ __ ] with it right yeah
yeah
so um
it says that
the if ever if all the components were
made in the u.s it would push the cost
up to 600 which they think would retail
it for 2 000. oh it should be like a
thousand bucks more wow
we got to pay what a lot more in [ __ ]
wages
yeah more than 12 dollars a day more
like [ __ ] 200 a day yeah probably
more than that right what's a union wage
for a factory worker i wonder in america
you know and then people say well they
the cost of living is less over there
like okay but so is the standard of
living you know i don't know man
i'm not i'm no perfect person
and where is this where they make these
phones in
a certain city in china like a real
[ __ ] i don't know i don't know enough
about it i probably should know more but
it's one of the dark things
about um the cell phone industry i think
they said the new one they're going to
make somewhere else why did i read it
did i read that somewhere that they're
going to make the news they changed
suppliers of something recently i don't
know
let's see is it canada did i read the
new iphone will be made in canada did i
read that or am i making [ __ ] up i could
google that next it says the average
assembly line worker makes about 13
bucks an hour wow
that's not a lot
i thought it'd be a lot more for a
warehouse worker
like 16 18.
isn't it crazy that if you paid him that
just paying them that a cell phone would
cost another thousand bucks
now you know what really kills me
that people jump off buildings
you know slave labor people don't give a
[ __ ] when it comes to apple
they just don't give a [ __ ]
they really don't give a [ __ ] who killed
who died
you know people stopped giving diamonds
because somebody suffered
tons of people suffer with those [ __ ]
iphones nobody gives a [ __ ]
every time i walk to a different city
and i walk in that mall
and that apple store it's pack jack
at whatever time you walk past the
[ __ ] mall today that apple store
they're they're [ __ ] just that those
registers are ringing yeah how i i
haven't heard of somebody going into an
apple store with 20 guns
like kim kardashian style is behind me
beside me
if i was 22 today like as crazy as i was
i'd be taking down those apple stores i
don't think anyone uses cash you don't
need the cash i take all that [ __ ]
merch within eight minutes and get it
down to the guys i can eat
to get down to a [ __ ] a stop watch
everybody down nobody wants to get hurt
i don't want to shoot nobody's [ __ ]
latte you know what i'm saying i don't
want to shoot nobody's kale salad
everybody's down
you take their iphones you take all the
iphones and stock somebody should be
doing this [ __ ]
nobody's doing this [ __ ] everybody's
scared the pieces
these phones are locked in they're like
you you could never sell them or use
them they're all locked into different
contracts like they sell phones that are
verizon phones they sell phones that are
18t phones you have to tell them when
you buy it at the apple store what
carrier are you okay we'll see if you
have that they go get they bring it back
like if you just bought a bunch of
phones good luck activating them they
have the serial numbers for all the
phones you show up in chinatown with a
thousand ipads
you want to see those things cooking
like boogie ipads would be a different
thing that'd be a different thing i show
up in chinatown with 100 ipads
watch them boogie those [ __ ]
show up with cash and take him out of
the tea kettle you understand me
yeah that's [ __ ] you gotta some
there's some little chinese get
somewhere
that's decoding [ __ ] phone i watch
that you know what though i gotta
disagree with you because you have to
sign that thing up to itunes if you sign
it up to itunes it's going to know what
what that computer is it's going to be
able to read that computer
and if you have a stolen computer it's
going to find out
unless you swiped you wiped the
operating system clean and installed
some new [ __ ] in there
in glendale
for 10 bucks he'll scrape a computer
brand new and your history is shipped
over there
and they're using your credit card
within [ __ ] minutes
that i watched
in the hotel room and i couldn't sleep i
watched
where america gets all the worst guns in
the world you know what they're now
philippines
we get we get all those guns without the
numbers like the good guns that's
yeah starts in the philippines a little
hut
it's a family that's been making 45
since jesus left chicago because the the
45 was created in the philippines to
shoot
american soldiers or something white oh
my god yeah yeah yeah yeah you can hand
make a gun these [ __ ] filipinos i
mean you didn't know that you didn't you
gotta see this no i figured the guns had
to have like put on drugs and guns well
do you know who makes guns now
no jesse james the motorcycle man that
guy opens
motorcycles yeah
but he uses hand like he makes guns
like he puts them together yeah but he
cheated on his wife i don't trust that
[ __ ] those guns will backfire
he's gonna pull a job
did the gun [ __ ] jam [ __ ] him
these filipinos these guns go directly
to oakland do they oh my god i was
watching this i'm like how did i not
know this [ __ ]
it's crazy how they make these 45s by
hand but somebody told me why they did
the 45 was either
for the hawaiians or the filipinos they
were made to either shoot either or
or they were to shoot the americans
something [ __ ] crazy
when you watch all this [ __ ] that's what
i know like they show computer theft on
here and how they do it there's
[ __ ] out there that could do
anything well
did you find it i found one in jamaica
not in no no drug thing and the guns
i was in shock i never knew that they
make the gun without the serial number
the serial number and how the gun is
like drugs like it starts for 300 in the
philippines
and then a thousand want to get to the
states in florida and then by the time
it gets to oakland the gun is 1600 hours
the same way how it goes across like
that look at that picture of the outlaw
josie wheels like back then how did they
make guns like what did they use for
manufacturing
isn't that wood in between yeah with the
handle and then the bottom piece they
probably have like at least a a dot what
is it called we have like
a mold for it yeah there must have been
some kind of mold right it would be
interesting like how big the company was
it made pistols back then was that a
huge couple who made the shotguns in
those these are all companies that from
these gun things when you look them up
like
what's the remington well no the italian
gun italian what's the name of that
italian
beretta like the beretta you know
that's a family business
they've been making i'm not a mafia
business like an italian family business
they've been making guns since time
immemorial
so it's like remington one of those
companies i read smith and wesson just
met them west and those guys been around
forever this was just
the regular [ __ ] whoever i'd be
interested i don't even know what year
well there's a bunch of there's there's
a um
like a west museum in bozeman montana
and they have all these old guns there
and you can go see guns from a long ass
time ago pretty sure it was in bozeman
either way they had guns all the way
back to muskets
and it's wild but there were companies
now that i'm thinking about it there's i
think remington was probably even around
back then winchester that was another
one like a big name company but i'm sure
there was some other big name companies
that i'm not aware of but when you look
at that you know what's interesting
about that looking at clint eastwood
that is supposed to be the 1800s right
like when did they invent the bullet
with the cartridge
where it could just load in there like
that in a revolver i mean was it even
100 years old what were you they should
be blinking
that's it that's yeah that's the
question right yeah yeah whatever year
they say
that was a revolver
that was not an old an old uh
that was not an automatic weapon 1835
yeah so they've been when did they kill
lincoln 1835. it was that year that was
the year of the i don't know i think
what was he in lincoln died and what do
you get shot with
wikipedia what lincoln gets shot with
all right lincoln got shot in 65 1865.
yeah wow so 30 years later you say 35
for the first one
so it was 30 years after uh the
invention of the gun you got shot
you know you want to hear crazy stop
between the invention of the airplane
and someone dropping an atomic bomb out
of the airplane it was less than 50
years
[Music]
how crazy is that
it's [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up
make google when was the invention of
the airplane or i could do it to it if
you're doing something else what was uh
i was trying to find the gunny showers
the invention it had to be like a
two-shot pistol with the adventure the
plan three shot pistols
[Music]
i don't think the sixth
thing was developed
i could be wrong i don't know yeah i
don't know how they had guns that you
had to put one at a time
like one bullet like the musket
like yeah like you had to open it if it
was all it was the one in the round you
had to put it in there and shoot them so
the wright brothers were the ones who
essentially there's a bunch of people
working at it but they were the ones who
invented the airplane yes
all right pistol just a regular pictures
it just says pistol
if you had a guess when do you think
they invented the airplane oh a
philadelphia derringer
uh
1935
i don't [ __ ] know you know i spoke to
18 bonkins before i got here uh 1900
1903.
jesus christ yes can you imagine being
that first couple guys nope can i talk
to you for a second man
listen i want you to help me with this
thing though
wow 1903 four miles south of kitty hawk
north carolina okay so they if they did
that they invented the airplane in 1903
and then
1947 was world war ii and they dropped
the bombs right wasn't it 47 uh i think
i've been 45.
so think of that that's 42 years 42
years later they're dropping bombs out
of them that's [ __ ] insane yeah
august 6 1945 that's insane and 70 years
later they had first class lounges with
a piano in them wow with a pig that was
cooked and you could go up and take the
[ __ ] pagan with an apple in his mouth
and a piano player on a
into first plane
you walk into first class and you had
cream and soap and shampoo and you had
colognes yeah and you could put the
colognes on
and people use people used to walk
around the second floor you could smoke
on planes listen if you get on the plane
and they still got ashtrays abandon ship
all right well there was it yeah okay
and there's planes
there's a ton of them that still got
ashtrays that you're sitting there
scratching your head
going what the [ __ ] am i doing on this
plane i'll never go back to paducah and
an armrest or something yeah yeah then
they are scary they're still planes with
cigarette [ __ ] it used to be a flight
that you could take out of la that
everybody would brag about but i never
got a chance to do it i think it was
like the warner brothers playing
i think warner brothers like one of the
big studios had a plane and they would
you could get a flight on it somehow i
don't remember how it worked like it was
really hard to get but they did it like
big shots and big movie stars and
celebrities and stuff that would fly on
this thing and they would fly you from
l.a to new york in this thing it had
like couches and it was set up like a
cool nightclub inside
it was just like people just lounge you
get like 50 people on this plane they
would just lounge
listen led zeppelin had a fireplace on
that plane you understand me did they
[ __ ] yeah
a little gas fireplace a [ __ ]
fireplace did they really you're being
serious don't be serious with actual
fire they had nixon's play
nixon's playing that fire in it they
took a fire like a little fireplace
where people could sit and drink a
whiskey
they had like nixon's plane
they bought like nixon's plane rented i
don't even want to google whether or not
nixon's plane actually have yeah yeah
google led zeppelin playing see what it
says on there
tremendous i know you guys i mean
would it would have a private plane
never be something you would want
led zeppelin's plan all right by the way
it's a thousand questions do i want a
plane do i look like i want a plane that
looks like harrison's [ __ ] forward to
you would you trust me on a [ __ ]
plane
yeah google whether or not it had a
fireplace
no just to let zeppelin play would tell
you he'll describe it the name of the
article is 70s rockstar party plane of
zeppelin god
they were probably balls they had a bard
they had a bar oh should i have to put
this up yeah watch this this is the real
deal these guys weren't [ __ ] around
when they came over here in 73 they had
the plan
and that manager that gangster from
england that was shooting people
he would get off the plane six foot
[ __ ] six you gotta see this really
these guys would look at this
wow led zeppelin
airlines god
were they the
i mean there's all the plagiarism things
right with them like people still say
they stole songs and riffs and stuff
like that but
do you think that's what
yeah refurbished in the early 70s by
team bobby sherman's manager
the plain palm disguise service among
others like zapping the stones
coke flex hey the top blue drop in the
70s
dark soup store that says keep going see
what it said it had on there
so let me you want me to read what this
is this is fascinating though hold on a
second scroll that down look at they're
saying here let's go down no up
sorry
so look at this the probable inspiration
for austin powers shagadelic 747 the
starship brimmed with gaudy
cheek delights there was a bedroom with
a king-sized waterbed a drawing room
with a fake fireplace a 30-foot brass
trim bar with a built-in electric organ
a prehistoric video system stocked with
everything from deep throat to duck soup
and two stewardesses to cater the velvet
trousered minstrels fresh from their
madison square garden gigs
holy [ __ ]
oh my god look at this this is their
plane they're hanging out with elton
john he's playing the organ
wow
[Music]
it was a flying [ __ ] gen palace
richard cole look at that look at him
with his shirt off look at robert plant
did he ever have a shirt button look at
how these guys rocked it they just left
their shirt wide open like that was how
you rocked it if you were a rock star
they never did a sit-up in their life
like look at that
look at the gallery or do you want look
at the picture of them
never just set up his life on the left
never did it was just cocaine
that was straight cocaine then but they
were just
gods they were like rock gods
i mean think about
what those guys represented back then
you could see their [ __ ] pressed
against their pants that was all yeah
that was look at that who the hell had
that before no shirt and everybody's
[ __ ] is like
tilted towards their left we'll see them
they're like all three well then one of
them
second to the right is uh jimmy page is
bucking the trend yeah led zeppelin was
that first
jimmy jimmy's got his dick going the
other direction look at this led
zeppelin was the first to lease the
plane
through a white knuckle flight from
oakland to los angeles
and a tiny falcon 20 business jet
terrorized the entourage oh so they got
a little tiny plane for a while and they
almost died one time led zeppelin
suffered from almost surreally bad press
rolling stone suggested the band changed
its name to limp blimp
and it was thought that starship might
earn the group some respect
it was an extremely useful tool because
inviting a journalist onto the plane the
story kind of wrote itself said danny
goldberg led zeppelin's publicist for
the tour who had been hired to gin up
positive coverage the novelty value was
significant so listen to what that's
like they're saying that rolling stones
weren't getting any respect
rolling stones never gave legends
rolling stone never gave led zeppelin
yeah they're never [ __ ]
exactly that doesn't make any sense yeah
how could they hate led zeppelin hold on
[Music]
like if you hear a whole lot of love how
could you hate that they they [ __ ]
panned all the albums how could they
panic so they had to eat [ __ ] at the end
because it doesn't really [ __ ] matter
dude when i first heard led zeppelin i
was 14 years old or 13 years old
somewhere around that it was when i
first moved to boston that's when i
first become there was a girl that lived
up the street that used to kind of
molest everybody but everybody let her
like she was 21 and we were all like
teenagers and she made out with like
everybody
um but she had great taste in music and
she introduced me to ac dc she
introduced me to the first song i ever
heard from led zeppelin was a black dog
and it blew your [ __ ] mind it blew
mine i couldn't believe what they were
saying yeah i was like wow when i saw
the post room and i'm like wait a second
these guys are [ __ ] crazy they were
doing something powerful that's for sure
like the the fact that rolling stone
didn't like them back then is so strange
i wonder what it was
listen man they put those things on
youtube and i watched them and i got a
little sad
they put the comparisons between songs
oh they're saying they're the same songs
and i got a little sad you know
did i know and i know what they were
thinking you know but
the trial that happened six months ago
was really [ __ ] crazy because
even me who was a led zeppelin lover i
could tell that there was something
something i could hear something there
it's when i first heard that song from
that [ __ ] white dude
and i'm like this is [ __ ] marvin gaye
song
how was this that marvin gaye song i
grew up on this [ __ ] song i know it a
mile away 100 yeah and all suddenly a
year later marvin gaye's estate marvin
gaye's estate did not [ __ ] around yeah
marvin gaye's estate was handled by his
son who it was minus
40 [ __ ] million in taxes and the
grapes and then he cut up remember the
california grapes i heard it through the
grapevine yeah that and the [ __ ]
albums he kept putting now he took all
the wrong songs out of the vault his son
turned that around and his son was a
savage so as soon as i heard that song
but with the led zeppelin
the the stairway to heaven
yeah they were guilty
they were guilty of a couple but i will
tell you something there's not a [ __ ]
jury to convict them
why not
why that
yeah i mean they cannot stay away to
heaven
because this is how it got me this is
how i answered it in my head okay i was
thinking about it and it came out in the
[ __ ] car
my wife was in the car and all of a
sudden dog i got goosebumps
and i thought my head was going to blow
up because they stole it but
there's one thing about this and i know
you the other night what was the song we
were singing as we walked into the
[ __ ] theater what was that what was
that song we were singing keep putting
on led zeppelin uh stay away to heaven
what was that song we were saying
how long have you heard that song in
your life what song was it do you
remember
just free the people to give my soul i
want to get lost in you how what what
does that song do to you what does that
song do to you you've heard that song
and you were kidding your mom played it
somebody played that jam fast forward
this league to the guitar solo fast
forward how far is that
[Music]
just a little 30 seconds and i didn't
figure it out until then
[Music]
you can't take that band there i was
like they can't they can't overrule this
no jewelry no keep it keep keep keeping
just listen to this power
this is real power this is part of who
the [ __ ] you are
yeah you know it's and it's beautiful
this is just beautiful it is so you
can't no jewelry they go you know
okay do me a favor go to um
go to uh led zeppelin stole
songs
you could do the show in the comparison
because the person who told me about
this was burr
he called me up and where he goes dude
it'll break your heart
it'll break your heart
when you hear it it'll break out they
[ __ ] stole they stole like a million
different songs yeah your glasses jump
yeah i do
what do you need
[Music]
oh my god who are you choking there no
i'm not joking that kid's god is tight
look at the size of me look at the size
of him that's hilarious that's a good
you're a good guy to work guard with
jesus christ like work sweeps with and
[ __ ] oh my god you know
and these guys they [ __ ] uh
[Music]
like if you somebody could sweep you
jesus christ and it's a totally
different kind of working out
i love it it's the best i love it it's
such a balls off i could smell the weed
such a good way to work out you know did
you find that video
uh i think so yeah yeah that's like two
different things from parents
let's listen
i think this is taurus yeah this is not
led zeppelin folks
so stop and think about do you think
they stole
[ __ ] yeah they did
[Music]
come on
i'm not a musician i don't know i don't
understand do you know anything about
chord progression lee do you know what
yeah he loves it i didn't know that
existed
see this is where we need eddie bravo
eddie bravo could explain to us what
that sounds like like what what what the
uh how it's the same song no this is
let's double zap one
[Music]
it's the same song
oh the first album is covered with
stolen [ __ ] this is actually a little
better yeah no no no this is
in their mind but they did steal it they
heard it and when they played together
yeah well they
look
let's just call it what it is you know
it's it's stealing does this the only
song that they have uh
that's i i just chose one first stairway
to heaven so i could get another one but
you know i think if you look at
the who they were they were amazing i
mean their finished product like what
they able to put together was [ __ ]
amazing and whether it came out of those
four guys heads or those four guys heads
and some other people's heads too it's
the
the effort the culminative effort of
those artists to put all that music
together and make these insane songs the
real problem is somebody didn't get
credit for it that's the real problem
the real problem is somebody didn't get
paid you know and they definitely used
it for their end product so if you
looked at it like say if you had a car
you put together a car
and uh there's a bunch of different
components there's a transmission
there's the engine but they want to put
your transmission in
you know but they don't want to pay you
for your design so they just copy it and
put it in there and then you find out
hey but this is all my engineering i did
all this research and development and
all you should have copied it exactly
they should they're supposed to say yeah
you're right here's some money and then
the question would be well how much
money they deserve that's the problem
because they probably deserve a [ __ ]
problem
that's how many times they played in
concert it's kind of oh it's kind of
they got forensic [ __ ] people in
there it would be insane so it wouldn't
just be a matter of a little bit of
money it'd be a matter of economy
changing money so it's going to be hard
to get someone to sign off on it and for
probably
i mean i don't understand too much about
how the legal system works but i would
imagine that the lawyers that represent
led zeppelin must be out of this [ __ ]
world yeah no they're big time that's
the that's that's the record label
they sell their soul to save yeah you
would be you would be betting against
the most ruthless savages in the history
except
listen
they [ __ ] relax they rob people
to death the music industry did you ever
read that courtney uh love uh article
that she wrote where she explained she
broke down the music industry
she broke down what everybody gets paid
it's really well written it's so well
written that they uh thought they
accused somebody else of writing it and
she was a she got a ghost writer that's
how well written it is
because it goes into detail about how
artists get [ __ ] and how musicians get
[ __ ] and where all the music goes or
the where the money rather for the music
goes and how little of it actually makes
it down to the artist this is back when
they were selling records now it's it's
weird because right now
the touring is where i guess the artists
might come on
and joe you said uh that you didn't
think someone a court would find them i
think if they got the right jury like a
younger a younger jury who didn't have
as much attachment to led zeppelin i
think they might see it from that point
of view like they i think it's well
known now that
artists don't make that much money from
their music anymore so i think like some
people might
i mean they tried to they said they
stole this in 1970
that was something that was the problem
right there that it was
47 [ __ ] years ago 47 years of oh in
the millions of dollars millions of
dollars like you were talking for that
song you might be talking like 500
million dollars or something crazy it
might be more than that that might be
like conservative
like you're you're talking about the the
if if not the biggest superband one of
the biggest superbands of all time that
toured everywhere and you gotta remember
in 1973 in this country
we did two billion dollars in music
sales i saw that on the 70s it was the
biggest year touring everybody was on
the road
everybody from richmond and fly the
temptations led zeppelin the stones
pink floyd everybody was on the road in
those days aerosmith this was a [ __ ]
masterpiece of people ted nugent did you
ever see searching for sugar man
no the one that won the oscar about the
musician yeah elvis or something like
that well no
was huge in south africa and he never
knew it he was a huge star and there's
all these legends about what happened to
him and how he died and you know but he
his and his music is good man it's good
it just for whatever reason it didn't
hit
in the 1970s when he released it and so
this guy became like
a laborer and he worked construction and
he raised a family and he stuck around
but he step he still kept like
practicing his music and then one day
someone found him
and they couldn't even believe it was
him they thought that he was dead and
someone found him and told him hey man
you you've been huge in south africa
forever huge
he was like what and he went over to
south africa like after he'd been poor
for like 30 years or something like that
you know like literally living in a
place where he's got like a wood stove
and he's burning fire in the wood stove
burning logs in there to stay warm they
show him doing this he goes over south
africa and sells out arenas
they can't even believe it when they see
him they can't believe it he starts
singing songs they know the words they
sing along with him he's coming back
from the dead it's insane he's it's more
than he's coming back from the dead it's
like this guy was a huge superstar
and
he was impoverished he was like he was
almost like
living a fake life for 30 years they
didn't even know
how do they become huge in south africa
they play this
could be
could be one guy found it sometimes that
[ __ ] happens
did he have an album out yeah he had a
couple and he made no money on him no
they didn't give him a [ __ ] dime they
apparently made he made one that he had
a chance to make the second one and he
really you know they they gave it a big
push but it just didn't catch
and they don't know why you know maybe
it was what the album looked like you
know maybe it was uh
people just didn't give it a chance but
it was good he's a good musician and
after that second album he quit but that
music made its way to south africa it
made me cry
it really did i just like it was
all about it somebody told me to watch
and i have forgotten all about now i'm
watching them dude i was getting tears i
was tearing up because i was watching i
was like this is
this is a this story is amazing because
this story is about this guy that just
became this weird sort of humble guy
who's really philosophical and kind of
zen about life and he gave all the money
away all the money made touring after it
became huge in south africa he gave it
away went back to living just like how
he was living before
at least that's what they tell you
that's the legend i hope not
well you know i don't know i mean maybe
he was happier that way maybe he just
decided that at his age he's in his 60s
at his his age all of a sudden becoming
this big star and going to south africa
and flying across the world and making
money and not knowing why you're doing
it and you know and everybody says
you're supposed to do it he didn't like
it i think he just wanted a quiet more
peaceful life and maybe still torn a
little bit but damn
i bought the album i bought uh whatever
he has out there whatever i could buy on
itunes is i think it's one it might be
two albums so i think it's one i'll make
sure he's getting the [ __ ] money
yeah they've been taking it from for the
last 30 years these [ __ ] now
itunes comes along
and gives you a 40
i wonder what they would give him in
south africa for all that all the times
they sold his records
listen man i heard something that john
oates daryl
knows
in the end of 1990 they had sold eight
million records and they both had fifty
dollars in their bank account
whoa
where'd you hear that on uh
eddie trunk
on serious radio that he's gonna release
a book now
the music business is as filthy as it
gets i don't get it
we had danny brown i tried to have him
explain to me
all this mixtape world and how i don't
get it
i don't get it i see an album i buy a an
album for 8.99
it sells a million albums what's that
8.9 million
i think right yeah 899 million no no
8.99 8.99 oh but just say think of nine
dollars okay that sells a million nine
million nine million [ __ ] dollars how
much does the artists get they got like
two million i wonder the record label i
walked into the weed store today and
they were playing billie jean
the video that's the first time i saw
him it was the last time you saw billy
jean 15 [ __ ] years ago
i started looking at it i thought about
that
that's when a record label put up
a half a mil for a video yeah
a half a [ __ ] meal you remember when
madonna had that
uh like a virgin
no no like prayer is that what it was
pepsi and she brought the black jesus
yeah people went [ __ ] bananas you
know all of them and then coke or
somebody signed michael jackson's his
hair went on fire yes yeah that's what's
going on because that's what started the
pain pill addiction
because when they when he died they
realized that whole thing was a wig
oh man he burped his hair off the whole
time it had been a wig he had scars in
the back and the whole thing oh wow they
lit him on fire and burnt his hair off
that's why he sued coca-cola whoever it
was pepsi coca-cola wow that makes sense
i mean if you especially consider all
the chemicals he used to have in his
hair
you know at 84 yeah so that's hair spray
is super flammable that's what started
the pain that's when he started telling
people he was getting pain in his neck
he couldn't sleep at night so that's how
he was getting all his medication
and then he go to these different
parties and mingle
and spread the word and they tell him
stop by tomorrow we got a [ __ ] bag of
goodies for you in the house wow
and that's what led to him you know
[ __ ] shooting whatever the [ __ ] he
was shooting at the end well he was
taking tranquilizers at the end they
were they were using like sedatives on
them to make them go to sleep so
essentially they were they were um
putting him under sedation every night
they were using anesthesia
they were just they were just conking
them out like but and i guess when you
do that you go out and [ __ ] but you
don't really sleep like part of what you
need is not just to be unconscious you
need to go through those cycles those
cycles in your head and when you're
under anesthesia you're not going
through those cycles
i'm not a doctor
no no no i get you it's like getting
surgery
it's like when i got my nose surgery one
minute you're there and then you're gone
you don't remember [ __ ] about what
happened
you wake up you don't really know if
you're tired or if you slept or not it's
kind of a weird feeling it is weird you
kind of think about the lights you see
the lights and you can't remember what's
going on so
i don't know how they could sedate you i
know if you get [ __ ]
done one time it's pretty [ __ ] bad
for you if you get done like if you get
anesthesia people watch it people say
it's not good
like these people get plastic surgery
way before the chick died
i had heard about that that there was a
problem well there's you know there's a
real problem apparently
one one things that happens
dr mark gordon wrote a paper about it
about
trauma
and
sedation long-term effects of sedation
for like major operations like heart
surgery heart surgery
something happens where um it can really
[ __ ] with your hormonal system like
apparently those long term
under sedation times when they're they
got you under anesthesia for a big
operation are super [ __ ] like your
body does not like it
when your body comes back a lot of
people suffer from depression not just
from the trauma of the operation itself
but also from the um destruct
disruptance of your immune system and
disrupt your non-immune system your
hormone system something about
going under the knife under that lung
does some wacky [ __ ] to you and it makes
people feel really listless and
depressed and it causes all sorts like a
whole cascade of mental issues and
depression
related issues can come just out of long
term it's anesthesia
once a month what are you angry about
okay and i'm not angry about anything no
it's just
it was it like when you go have surgery
doesn't the anesthesiologist have to
like they have a person there with you
the whole time that's not what we're
saying no no but when i'm like didn't
michael jackson just get that and they
let him sleep like it's day like it's
dangerous like what you're saying is
yeah that's why he's dead exactly yeah
but sometimes you go to mexico for
surgery you save eight grand and there's
no anesthesiologist just a mexican named
paco that comes in and shoots you a
syringe just by looking at you he's five
foot six
maybe 160. dude i've heard a lot of
people go to mexico to get [ __ ] done no
they have to there's a lot of stem cell
stuff a lot of stem cell cancer
they [ __ ] cure you down there really
pink bang boom i know a guy who did one
of those things what do you do that
gofundme
he got 50 g's he went to mexico really
six months he's healed this guy used to
work downtown take a bus to north
hollywood get off and drive his bike
up north a few [ __ ] miles on this
railroad track right here
he had to work to woodland hills yeah he
was in good shape and he got that
[ __ ] cancer
bike seats
no way no bikes he wore his ass that's a
joke it might be who knows why lance
armstrong got he got that thing and the
lance armstrong got it because he was
shooting heavy duty
that dude was even doing antifreeze when
he rode his bike in the wintertime [ __ ]
him he lost a nut dog yeah and i thought
about that one night high as [ __ ]
i had friends that shot coke i had
friends that went on endless cycles and
they're still cooking they got their
hair they look good
[ __ ] his nut blasted off i have a
friend i have a friend who did i told
you did blo and his mother would shoot
him with the steroid at the same time
he's still alive and kicking living in a
half a million dollar house in
pennsylvania and atlanta strong blew a
[ __ ] nut please stop saying well you
got cancer sure how do you think he got
cancer there well duncan got it too yeah
[ __ ] got the same cancer duncan got
it from reading all that bullish [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] gutsy after a while you know
what i'm saying especially when you're
from the south you can't be reading that
[ __ ] oh my god
i'm still got it because they go on
endless cycles you were telling me they
won they go on oxygen some [ __ ] that to
give them more epo epo that [ __ ] a
[ __ ] cat now do a lot of those
bicycle people get that [ __ ] i don't
think so
i think it's just a genetic thing i
think uh who knows i mean it could be
stress related there's a lot of factors
that could play into it when someone
gets cancer
you know some of it's environmental some
of it's genetic some of it's uh
you know
just
dumb luck you know diet has a lot of a
lot to do with apparently apparently
like what you were saying about the guy
that you know that kicked it by getting
rid of sugar
apparently that is a pretty profound
effect you can eliminate sugar and a lot
of simple carbohydrates from your diet a
lot of refined flour apparently has a
pretty good effect on your uh level of
inflammation and your immune system
strengthens
and that alone helps a lot of people who
are battling anything whether it's
cancer or what have you
but there's a lot of people that swear
that that can turn it around especially
if you can get your body burning fat
it's really interesting stuff man
because most of our diet like pretty
much the majority of the american diet
is filled with some kind of sugar
something to keep going even low-fat
milk and sugar in it did you know that
no low-fat milk has sugar in it so it
doesn't taste terrible
there's [ __ ] sugar and low-fat milk
because because sugar is not fat that's
how [ __ ] we are when it comes to
food
like almost every like granola bars you
think you're oh i'm getting a granola
bar i'm eating hopefully you're eating a
goddamn candy bar that's a candy bar oh
it isn't sugar
yeah all that stuff makes your your body
inflamed and it makes you your
it [ __ ] up your insulin levels it does
all sorts of weird stuff to your body
because you're not your body's not
designed to take in that amount of sugar
like the body that we have today is the
same bodies that people had ten thousand
years ago when there was no refined
sugars when you got your sugar from
fruit and that's what people know that's
that's how your body is designed when
your body wants to eat a pear it gets
fruit it chews into it it gets the sugar
and everything attached to all the fiber
and that's how your body digests it
healthily but when you get
scooped up a spoonful of [ __ ] sugar
that came from some factory and they
figured out how to suck it out of
sugarcane or whatever the [ __ ] they get
it from beets you know there's a bunch
of different sources of sugar that they
extracted from but it's a refined sugar
and you're getting in a form that your
body doesn't know what to do with it
doesn't have that
ever in nature so all that corn syrup
like when you get like a coca-cola that
is filled with something your body has
no idea what it is it's like how is this
in liquid your body's like what the [ __ ]
is this like this this dude's got 25 30
grams of sugar coming at me in a liquid
form and like your body doesn't know
about anything like that in nature so
you you get fat you feel listless it
gets you you get tired you go up and
down that's all insulin crashing
so those guys are getting cancer i was
drinking [ __ ] 22 cokes a day i know
exactly oh
i know exactly how hard was it to get
off in the morning i went from coke to
diet coke
then i just got clean and sober diet
coke is not better i i do know every now
and then
when i'm getting crazy
getting crazy i'll have me a diet coke
let me tell you something i could if i
taste the coke now i could feel the
difference oh yeah it's horrible you
leave that going oof i'll never drink
that again you get used to that flavor
you get used to that corn syrup taste
with the carbonation it's cold
dog listen that was a buttered roll
coca-cola type of dude growing up man
who knows how bad it was for you at
those early ages when your body's
developing who the [ __ ] knew you know
what the biggest [ __ ] bait and
switch act in the world is
fountain soda
was the last time you had a fountain
soda that tasted remotely as good as one
that's right from a can they just aren't
period
cokes i like fountain sodas it's okay
with sugar it's okay but it's not the
same thing it's not like you don't enjoy
it like if you get a diet coke from a
fountain it's okay it's okay it's you
know it's not like you don't enjoy it
but it is not as good as out of the can
when you get it out of the kitchen
disgusting you're getting the the full
formula when you get out of the can it's
a consistent experience every time yeah
you get a cold coke you crack it open
you drink it it tastes the same way
every time same thing with a diet coke
same way every time but if you go to a
fountain you get some weird sub flavors
things are watered down sometimes they
get lighter bubbles yeah
it's coke and they stick some funky ass
rc cola syrup in that machine oh and no
arsenal's just i was there [ __ ] cola
[ __ ] you can't drink the cuban from
coca-cola i drank that [ __ ] for years
jorgen do you remember when you were a
kid and you were poor and you did
generic soda i used to have do you
remember that coca-cola
i used to have coca-cola in my house but
my mom at the bar
used to sell bar soda
so coca-cola 7-up was lemon up oh that's
hilarious cola was up cola or something
crazy root beer had a different name
so my mom would bring the cases to the
house of lemon up
coke a [ __ ] up dr pepper that tasted
like turpentine
and uh something else like diet like in
those days the big diet soda was tab
tab was right
[ __ ] with a slice of lemon in it
good googly moogly that was saccharin
right that was yeah that was okay
that first diet soft drink tab and girls
always drank tabs i'll have a tab
tabs like my mom's friends they would
all have a tab and tahitian treat was
when you got from you went to chicken
delight
when you went to chicken delight and got
three pieces of chicken with french
fries they always had tahitian heat like
a [ __ ] that's that red soda let
me ask you this go ahead how the [ __ ]
did coca-cola ever gain any ground over
root beer when root beer is so much more
delicious they had cocaine
that's right all those years people were
drinking that [ __ ] what did they take
cocaine yeah are you ready for this yeah
they didn't
they don't have the active ingredient in
cocaine but they're flavored with coca
leaves
they use coca leaves and you know
coca-cola gets its coca leaves from a
manufacturer that strips them to make
medical grade cocaine in new jersey yes
in new jersey
there's a huge huge industry for medical
grade cocaine
and what people don't know like well
cocaine is legal no it's not no cocaine
is not illegal cocaine is illegal for
you but it's not illegal for the medical
industry so they bring in coca leaves
and they use the flavor from that cocoa
leaves to this day
to flavor coca-cola
what medical use does cocaine have
you can make lidocaine with it which is
a numbing agent they put on people when
they're having operations they pump that
[ __ ] up my nose so when they say it's
liquid cocaine it literally is liquid
cocaine
that's different lidocaine is different
because it doesn't have the psychoactive
effects but what it does do is it makes
you feel like [ __ ] it doesn't have like
if you ever put that stuff on you
lidocaine it makes you feel like [ __ ] i
put some on my back last week because i
had a really bad sunburn like real bad i
went to mexico and i [ __ ] up and i
didn't put sunscreen on my back i was
just sitting out there for a while and i
burnt
hard where the next day was sweating and
i was like ah like just agony right so
they put this lidocaine on me and i felt
like let a little numb like it numbed it
a little bit but the way i felt for the
rest of the day was so shitty you just
feel like if the cocaine without the up
yeah so that's what it probably is it's
the cocaine without that you feel real
down you feel real weak like after like
an hour or two like i guess it's almost
like what cocaine would do you but you
feel like like my appetite was
suppressed i just felt like
it was just this was just some
over-the-counter [ __ ] there's just some
uh sunscreen spray that has a small
amount of lidocaine in but just putting
that [ __ ] or sunburn spray putting that
[ __ ] all over my back
like [ __ ] with my system like i could
tell i could feel it because it's the
same feeling that i got when i had my
nose done when i had my nose fixed and
they cleaned out my deviated septum they
pumped all this lidocaine up there and
then i went out to dinner that night and
i was thinking i was feeling weak
i feel like god i feel like why am i
dragging ass like that
it weighs on your body yeah like i felt
weak like physically
on your body not your immune system but
yes your whole
when you do blow
you feel like you got hit by a [ __ ]
train the next day i'm so glad i avoided
that thank god god thank god you gotta
go brother no are you sure yeah no i
thought you know even attend just asking
me if we could go we can stay no no
we're good to go i just didn't know what
the [ __ ] is going on
i got to ask you a few questions you
know like dominick cruz says something
very interesting
when he came to the show in buffalo he
said
that it's really a lot of mental stuff
you know fighting
and that's been dawning on me like i've
been thinking about he said that when
guys don't make weight sometimes at the
mentor and i was like wow i never
thought about it dominique cruz is a
great guy to ask anything about mma
because he's so knowledgeable he's been
doing it for so long and he's a smart
dude and he's always thinking it through
he's constantly thinking things through
and he's you guys were really good
saturday man he's great no you guys
together were everybody was really good
john attic knew when to talk
he's like that he's like a meathead like
either went to talk and he was very good
but he couldn't compete with you two
guys
you guys were on the money especially
with the chris weidman incident i i saw
it i i thought there were legal needs
from the jump
oh here's two reasons why it's hard for
murgliana first of all he's a giant like
you have to understand dan mergliat is
like six foot five 300 pounds he's a
huge man i mean he's [ __ ] huge he
towers over most of the fighters and so
he's above these guys and if mousasi
is pinning down
um weidman so he's got him in a headlock
right and he's pulling him down he's
kneeing him in the face like he was
think of how tall mergliatta is in the
first place right like this now think
he's looking down at these guys kneading
each other in the head he's got to stay
close by in case something happens
there's no way he could see those hands
from where he was standing so he took a
educated guess based on his many many
years of refereeing that both hands were
down and it was so close
you would have to be
on the other side of the ring looking at
the ground to know whether or not it was
touching if you're above it the way
mergliata was how could he know he
really couldn't know and it's not his
fault he's an excellent referee the
fault is that the the athletic
commission under situations like this
doesn't use an instant replay and they
should because it's the fair thing to do
to make sure that the fight is it's fair
and i think weidman could have gone on i
think had there been a question whether
or not it was legal they could look at
the instant replay and then they make
the call the the the strikes are legal
we're gonna continue and you either
continue them from the exact same
position and say ready go
or you have a protocol in place like you
have to separate them go back to corners
and re-engage which is bad for musashi
because mousasi had him in a good
position and was landing strikes
so it's impossible for dan mergliatta to
um to be absolutely certain from where
he was standing as big as he is looking
down like that i would just imagine it
probably looked like wide men's hands
were touching when we saw it in the
replay i asked them to show me different
angles different angles yes i'm like
because at the first they said look it
looks like it's illegal and then i said
i don't see his fingers i want to see
his fingers let me see his fingers and
then when we went to one where you see
his fingers you can see musasi lift him
up which is what you're supposed to do
so the only reason why weidman had his
hands down like that is because he
thought that could prevent him from
getting hit he didn't have his hands
down like that because it's an offensive
gesture he's not like putting his hands
down there's because it's a next move
you know what he's doing is he's dealing
with the fact that
musashi has his neck he's dealing with
the fact he's getting need in the head
and he's thinking the best way to stop
is to put my two hands down
because like that's not a position that
you would ever be in if you were trying
to hurt somebody right so what he's
trying to do is trying to stop the knees
or figure out what to do and catch his
his mind because he's been tagged a few
times in this round he got hurt and
those two knees hit him hard and then
the referee tells him it's an illegal
knee so he said he's like okay let me
take this time to take a break i deserve
it i got hit with an illegal knee
so in his eyes he's doing what you're
supposed to do if somebody fouls you in
his eyes i got fouled he doesn't know he
got hit with two [ __ ] hard knees
right they tell him it was illegal he
thinks it's illegal so he goes on about
it like it's illegal so he sits down
then the doctors come over and examine
him and then they
someone tells him i believe it was john
mccarthy tells dan mergliatta that it
was a legal knee he's like it was legal
i just watched the replay he shows it to
dan
there's nothing dan can do now we've
showed the replay over and over now to
the to the people that we're watching on
pay-per-view and we're like they're
illegal these needs are legal this is
just a mistake
and so then they don't know what to do
they don't really have a protocol in
place so they stop the fight and they
give a tko victory to geiger musassi
which is crazy because dan was in no way
going to stop the fight right there like
it wasn't like wideman was getting hit
so hard he was right about to stop it
and then they said oh those needs are
illegal they weren't illegal but i was
going to stop it anyway so let's stop
the fight it's not that no it's the
fight was going on and it was stopped
just because of a mistake a mistake by
the commission that they didn't
understand they didn't have a good
protocol in place to to start a fight up
and they don't have a protocol in place
to check an instant replay under really
really difficult to discern violations
like this because it's really hard for
me
a professional commentator who's
right next to the cage i'm right there
dude i'm touching the floor where the
cage is on and i can't figure out if
it's legal or not i have to watch the
replay so dan in the heat of the moment
i mean he's watching two of the best
hundred and eighty-five pounders in the
world right gengar mousasi is tagged
wideman wyman keeps taking him down it's
a [ __ ] battle man it's a battle
between two world-class fighters and
wyman's got hard he could have come back
from that he's taking those hard knees
who knows what he would have done he
might have pulled guard and put mousasi
on top of him and got the sweep and the
round goes look what just happened with
darren elkins and and and and that that
crazy comeback that he had did you see
that fight that you had jesus christ
mursaat bectic who's his [ __ ] super
high level up and coming guys this was
this weekend no this was like two see
two oh yeah i saw that one yeah he took
the beat into the beating of his life to
the third round that he knocks the guy
out and it was the world erupted right
into the place
a guy like weidman is just like a guy
like darren elkins he can come back from
the dead
you might stop him i mean darren elkins
was stopped chad mendes [ __ ] him up
but he might [ __ ] you up in the third
round too so you've got to give a
champion like wideman the benefit of the
doubt so the problem i don't believe
that it was dan mergliat's fault i think
dan thought he was doing the right thing
and his his
mindset is to protect the fighters at
all time if it's an illegal knee he's
got to step in i just think it was so
close it was hard to tell and in the
heat of this exchange it's all crazy and
it's a very high level fight it's super
important it's in new york and so the
when the commission didn't know what the
[ __ ] to do that's when it became a
problem that's when almost
i wish somebody was there
like what i would have done i would have
said don't stop the fight because the
fight wasn't going to be stopped let's
restart the fight from the position that
it's in right there
where are you going
oh
you need some air
so uh
i wouldn't have stopped the fight it
wasn't his it wasn't his decision to
stop the fight it was the commission's
decision i'm pretty sure and i think it
was just because they didn't know what
else to do i think they just didn't know
they didn't have a thing to do in place
it's hard it takes a while to figure out
how to correctly
referee and judge and officiate in uh in
a state athletic commission that hasn't
had mixed martial arts before and all
sudden they have it so you don't have a
lot of expense or experience referees
the referees are gonna have to come from
other places guys like big john or dan
mergliat and then the commission
unfortunately even though the referees
were in place that were really high
level there's a commission that's really
not used to doing this and it's not
their fault they just they just don't
have the experience nevada state has it
down california has it down andy foster
in california he might be the best guy
in the business he's a former fighter a
lifelong martial artist super smart guy
and he's on on the ball with everything
with wing cutting he's on the ball with
drugs he's on the ball with he wants to
have more weight classes you want a
weight class every 10 pounds he wants to
like do hydration tests on fighters and
keep him from from doing this wants to
prevent them from doing this no do they
have instant replay in california and
nevada is that yes i do believe they
have it in nevada i do not know if they
have it in california actually can you
look that up find out what states have
uh instant replay i think they have to
say new jersey i'll treat you like
you're jamie and i don't know just for
that i'll give it an instagram i'll ask
someone to google i don't think they
they had to play new jersey something
happened in new jersey they should do it
everywhere it's just no reason to not
have it there's no reason to not have an
instant replay just in case if there
seems like there's some sort of a foul
if it's an eye poke if it's a groin shot
like if you can't look at an instant
replay how can you tell and there have
definitely been fights where people have
lost where they probably should have the
their opponent should have been
disqualified like where they got kicked
low and it didn't look like it got
kicked low to the referee and they
stopped the fight and that has happened
before
um that happened with james krauss when
he fought bobby green
in on a military base one of those fight
for the troops and he he got hit with a
low shot and then another one he might
have got hit with three but he
definitely got hit with two and the last
one was a shin right across the cup i
mean you could hear a crack it wasn't an
intentional shot it's just one guy's
really tall one guy's not as tall
neither guys are dirty fighters they're
both honorable fighters it's just an
accidental foul it just happens man
but when it happens i mean look like
it's not no one's trying to kick
somebody in the balls most of the time
most of the time a guy's trying to kick
the leg and he just misses like you
can't kick everything you aim at
otherwise you'd just be lighting each
other up i mean that's the whole thing
it's hard to hit people so like that's
why anderson silva kicked chris wyman's
knee like that he didn't want to he
wanted to hit him on the inside of the
leg but wyman got his leg up in time and
then smashes his
his [ __ ] shin bone snaps in half
that's easy that just shows you one of
the best of all time if not the best of
all time my idea is like him and fedor
the two greatest fighters that have ever
walked to face the planet i give
anderson a nod but it's probably a lot
of because i experienced him live in
person maybe if i experienced fedor in
person i would give him the nod or maybe
just call it a draw you know but even he
couldn't stop from breaking bones by
hitting the wrong things fedor broke his
hand a couple of times anderson broke
his leg they all bro everybody misses
you can't so getting upset at somebody
for kicking somebody in the nuts they
didn't mean to kick him in the nuts for
the most part you know i mean i'm sure
it's happened before but most of the
time it's an accident
but i throw a leg kick you move back
three inches it's that [ __ ] or he's
throwing a kick at the same time you're
throwing a kick that's more likely
i just kicked guys in the balls all the
time accidentally because i was short
because i was fighting guys who were
tall and i was five eight and these guys
were like six two would both kick at the
same time i'd kick them right in the
nuts accidentally
just happen
just like if you're super aggressive
you're not allowing someone like
openings you just try to attack all the
time there's a lot of collisions you
know when you have collisions anything
can happen
like one guy kicks the same time you're
kicking and see whoever gets there first
whoever gets there first whoever gets
past you know knees and shins and
whoever sneaks it in there
it's just unfortunate for wideman
unfortunate for mousasi unfortunate for
the whole division
i don't know if they will who knows
there might be a reason why one of them
gets a shot of the title
yeah see mousasi is
one of the best fighters in the world
but he's lost a few times
i mean guys have beaten him jacare
manhandled him pretty recently he
submitted him
he just got him on the ground and went
through him he's a goddamn shark jack
ray is a [ __ ] shark man he gets you
on the ground
he still has oh yeah no don't give me
his still could turn this around you
know he's dirty well your ryan hall
knocked him out too no no listen i'm
saying he's a bad [ __ ] do not
get me wrong i'm not just diminishing
his abilities i'm his biggest fan i
think musashi's cool customer he goes in
there deadpan doesn't give a [ __ ] how
many fights lights up anybody he said 50
professional fights this weekend was his
50th professional fight yeah he was
[ __ ] like cool as a cucumber super
respectful you know he's very respectful
of chris weidman but
said it like he felt it you know it's
like look he said he said about wyman
because why was game in the system he
was trying to not get need in the head
that's why he put his hands down there
he didn't put his hands down there to
fight he was trying to get out of it and
then when he got hit with the illegal
knee he acted like he couldn't go on he
was hoping that they were going to stop
the fight that's musashi's take on it so
the whole thing is
it's unfortunate very interesting but
musashi's a bad [ __ ] you see how
good a striker is in that fight he just
you realize like wow listen he took him
down but he kept getting up
and even the scrambler when he mounted
him he's [ __ ] sucked out the back
door i was really impressed he did his
homework so i thought it was all
starting to come together from assassin
like yeah i really thought
so we'll see the difference between a
wideman who's a really high level
submission artist he's a real high level
i mean he's a he's a bad [ __ ]
and his ground and pound is excellent
he's really world class with his with
his wrestling on his ground and pound
and then there's another level of the
matrix removed and that's guys like
damian maya that's guys who just
constrict they get people like carlos
condit and just constrict them
well they don't even have a chance do
you see oliveira versus will will uh oh
my god will brooks this weekend same
[ __ ] same [ __ ] same [ __ ] i was saying
before the fight i was like oliveira has
a super technical ground game like he's
got submissions in all sorts of
different ways calf slicers rear naked
chokes guillotines he gets you on the
ground you're in a world of [ __ ] he's a
bad [ __ ] and the same way he
submitted that guy with a standing rear
naked he did that to efrain escudero in
his ufc debut where was that frame today
when you said that i was like well i
don't know he had a few wins in the ufc
he fought mexico he had a win over there
he's looking really good he was looking
uh way more technical and more relaxed
and he's with um john crouch now
with benson henderson down there in
arizona
a lot of real good fighters i didn't
know ryan beta went to bellator yup he
went to bellator too they threw some
money out yeah and uh so did lorenz
larkin
lorenz larkin has is fighting douglas
lima who's the champion in bellator
that's a big fight it's a scary fight
they have a real division now okay they
have lima they have korushkov korskov is
a guy that [ __ ] up benson henderson
he's a bad [ __ ] from russia and
then you got douglas lima who just
knocked out karshkoff it was a great
fight but lima cracked him and you got i
mean if they were smart they'd bring
back ben askren because the ufc doesn't
want ben askren the bellator should take
ben asking and bring him back where is
he then he's over in one fc and they're
throwing all this money around ben
asking could spank some [ __ ] people
his wrestling is so [ __ ] good that he
manhandled lima lima just couldn't do
anything with him he's done it to a lot
of guys did the cars cop man handle them
they can't do anything to him just takes
him down and holds him down and beats
the [ __ ] out of him there's nothing they
can do about it he's just so much better
as a wrestler than all those other guys
that when he gets in there with him he
he almost like makes the fight boring
for some people but for me it's
fascinating especially if you know how
good these guys are and you see asgard
just dragging him to the ground left and
right and takes a shot too man takes
serious shots coming in takes knees to
the chin eats them like candy grabs guys
dumps them on their ass and holds them
down there and punches him in the face
and it's very few guys have been able to
stop him in fact i don't think anybody i
think he's jay here on from the ufc was
the only guy gave him a tough fight
because he's a good wrestler that was a
real close fight so the next card is may
for bellator no the ufc for ufc yeah may
12th yeah but i was just saying that
there's like that division as rory
mcdonald now right rory and somebody
else right who else rory mcdonald lorenz
larkin douglas lima they got there's a
serious division at 170 now
so
that's good for everybody that means
these divisions even outside the ufc are
stacking up and it could get to the
point someday in the future
where you know velcro belt or viacom you
know they could develop some huge
superstar some conor mcgregor style
superstar and there could be a big money
fight with a superstar from the ufc and
a superstar from that organization an
undeniable thing sort of like what's
going on with mcgregor what's going on
with mcgregor right now is mcgregor is
facing an undeniable like
floyd mayweather is an undeniable force
undeniable when it comes to financial
advantage for being in business with him
he's floyd mayweather he's one of the
biggest pay-per-view if not the biggest
pay-per-view seller in boxing history
right so him versus connor is just
there's so much money there everybody
will work together and that could
conceivably happen someday with bellator
and they're doing the right thing to get
into that kind of a position
you know by having like really legit
guys like lorenz larkin super underrated
guy lorenz lark is one of the most
underrated guys in the sport
and then de lima who's a [ __ ] beast
rory mcdonald was still one of the
baddest [ __ ] on the planet he's
super well-rounded he might school all
those guys he might school them all then
you've got paul daly paul daley's over
there
semtex that [ __ ] knocks people
dead he's just knocking people dead
he has the the nastiest left hook in all
of mma
just cracks guys and he's a left-handed
guy but he fights orthodox so his left
hand is his power hand but it's his
forward hand
he'll knock you out with either hand
don't get it wrong like he his last
fight he knocked dude out with a flying
knee
really tough kid too just boom
hit him with the same kind of flying
knee that yo romero hit wideman with
just one of those with the guys out
before he even goes to the ground and
they bounce
but paul daley does that to everybody
he's terrifying
they got that michael page two guy you
ever see that karate guy he's the guy
that broke cyborg skull where cyborg is
skull caved in and they literally put
plates in it you see that this that
guy's over there too
that's the same division
so that's a division full of killers so
one guy could rise to the point where
and that's good for everybody that's
good for the fighters everybody makes
more money it's good for the ufc it's
good for them
i barely got enough time to watch the
ufc all right leave me alone with
bellator i don't know nothing about
bellator you gotta watch every time i
turn it on like what am i watching i'm
so spoiled with the ufc watching the
shoots and stuff did you see bellator
kickboxing did you see that this weekend
i had some friends in that otherwise
nothing it's pretty badass john wayne
park was in there he's always fighting
he's always beating somebody up smoking
cigarettes
no no no he doesn't smoke cigarettes
what's the guy that smokes cigarettes
there's one joe schilling joe schiller
yeah that's the manistee he didn't fight
this one no not this card but he's
fighting for bellator kickboxing too
what do you got the rest of the week
tarzan just hanging out doing some sets
you know
doing tripoli show in the main room on
wednesday triple show the naughty show i
don't know he's just he's put together
his own show wednesday in the main room
callan's doing it shaw's doing it
brian's got a show too i'm doing brian's
show over at a laugh actor
hollow you're on everybody [ __ ]
having some fun
how fun was buffalo it's a good time
buffalo's always good that late show was
late though man 11 o'clock at night is a
late show you know on a friday i'd be
honest with you they were a lot better
than what i thought oh yeah they were
great i saw people at seven o'clock
getting tuned up
for the 11 o'clock show i thought it was
going to be hand to hand combat
comedy and i was prepared for it i was
like it's going to be hand to hand
and i gotta tell you something they
were very well behaved other great i
watched a half hour you're set they were
very well behaved yeah they were great i
was in shock
for an eleven o'clock show were you
going somewhere interesting now where
are you going this weekend
when are you going next you're going
somewhere next i go to oxnard oh that's
right you're doing levity in oxford
field
have you done that place yet at the
oxnard place no this is my favorite it's
[ __ ] great i'm doing 420 weekend then
i go to
milwaukee to see duke rufus oh yeah i
fly the next day in michigan oxnard is
like a road club a really good road club
like they're super happy that someone's
coming out there because for the longest
time they had to drive you live oxnard
you live an hour and 10 hour and 20
outside the city you they had to drive
into hollywood to watch shows so when a
guy like you come to them they're so
happy to drive 10 minutes from their
house and the club's amazing
it's a big place too it's like 300 and
something people maybe even more might
be 400. look i told you i was really
impressed with lebanese
very impressed very impressed yeah
they're doing good [ __ ] the chef at
levity live was the chef from oxnard he
had just worked the weekend with you
but they're hiring a new chef at
lebanese live so he's out there training
i had a phenomenal time at that club it
really opened up my eyes i was like
jesus christ
i forget up this this part of new york
oh yeah this part of new york is [ __ ]
different you know it's uh
it just i i missed that i missed that
914
attitude it's in rockland county and you
have a little aggressive you have a
little aggressive what's the other place
that westchester is close by yeah i
missed that that's the new radio
new rochelle people were there bronx
people came bonkers very yonka's very
yeah yonkers people there very [ __ ]
uh
tremendous my friend i'm happy you
[ __ ] made time for me dog oh i'm
happy to do it i love you you came down
here on monday night [ __ ] around
talking about different [ __ ] i love this
place i haven't been here i love how you
got it set up
did you that's what's going on look up
this shape did you put all these lights
in i know kevin our friend from uh
what's the name of the company after bus
after buzz oh he does it professionally
he could do it in two [ __ ] minutes
he's a lighting guy like a tv yeah he
just had a funny feeling about lights
and stuff like that that's badass just
to give it it's awesome you guys have a
cool spot i love it i love
i love podcasts
and i like the way the studio looks and
stuff like that
but it was always like i always wanted
this to be something that you listened
to and like it felt illegal that you
were listening to it like this doesn't
feel like i i don't want to i don't want
it i never wanted it to be polished like
i wanted to be like
yeah like they had to sit back and come
on it's like listen to led zeppelin in
cuba yeah you gotta listen to it under
the stairs
you know it's [ __ ] crazy can you
imagine that you ever listen to doug's
it starts mid-sentence
it's like he's in the middle of like
[ __ ] this gotta be a is it on is this
[ __ ] thing on it's on
you know and he just you know he's at a
bar he's got this place in his house
he's always set up i think right well
he's got a place in his house like it's
called a fun house it's got like a bar
and it's all painted weird colors and
[ __ ]
and they do the podcast live from there
and everybody's drunk and chiming in and
it's hilarious
and you know it's just dug kind of
holding court and the beautiful thing
about it for him he says is that he
doesn't have to go to open mic nights
he's like he can just do that and when
he does that
from from there like he's riffing and
ranting all the time and that's allowing
him to develop material he gets ideas
and works on them and they allow him to
riff and rant he puts it on once a week
i think he does whatever the [ __ ] he
wants he's done like series of them was
like three or four in a day like he did
like like four or five in a day once
they were all 10 minutes long we'll be
right back you know there's an episode
of [ __ ] what is it 11 what are you up
to 11.
this is such a character i mean he's
he's the real deal you know there's a
lot of people that like pretend to be
that kind of there's ton of them in
hollywood they want to be santa but he's
no he lives seven miles from mexico is
bingo good she's better yeah she's
better are they together yeah he's
helping her she's going through she she
fell and hit her head
and uh apparently uh i would i would
have to get the full
uh run down from him what the exact
medical condition was but i know she was
in a coma for a while it took her a
while to come out of it
super scary [ __ ] man someone falling
down a flight of stairs and hitting her
head is super bad but apparently she's
talking now her sense of humor is back
so she's recovering she has seizures
i don't know some type of seizures i
don't know
there's a there's a cave for sale
in uh doug's community [ __ ] cave out
in the desert have you seen it no yeah
it's like it's a famous cave and doug
was talking about like buying the cave
like a bunch of people he bought like
five houses he owes half the ticket to
the city
whatever houses go up for sale he winds
up buying them
he could one like no [ __ ] that one
day could be dugtown
like it really could like
hang them high all you'd have to do the
town red and locked it up he could yeah
he could be the mayor
have his own bar isn't it the king of
the town now he got his fans to make it
the number one small city in america or
something
like the number one rustic town in
america well it was really cool even
before that like before that people did
enjoy that town it's an artist community
it always had a good reputation that's
why you moved there in the first place
but what i'm saying is like
if if
if you really want if someone a real
estate agent came in
and the real estate agent was like like
look we're going to turn this to the
doug town and this we're going to we're
going to offer you a lot of money for
your house how much your house worth and
the guy's like why like you know 150 000
or whatever how much the houses cost and
he would uh they would find someone from
somewhere that wants to relocate to
bisbee and uh they have enough money to
buy a house
and so they go i want to move to doug
town i've heard there's minimal rules
the bars are open 24 hours a day
and uh you get to meet doug stanhope and
then people just start moving in if you
have a a big world right
350 million people in this country
you're telling me you couldn't find 30
000 people that want to live with doug
stanhope oh please they're all happy a
heartbeat
so you just get this real estate agent
to start [ __ ] putting deals together
because
people start buying houses like cop land
yeah well the house is just doug land
and they'd probably be a few scalpers
who buy houses they pretend oh i'm a
huge fan of dogs doug's been amazing
from the beginning and then they buy the
house try to spike it up and sell it for
even more there'd be a lot of that for
sure
but you really could do that like he
is one of the few guys that could really
could legitimately start a cult and i
would think about going i would i would
go oh i can't do that i'd go down there
with viceland
that's what i'd [ __ ] do and look at
those lunatics bring david cho
and go down there
[ __ ]
he's having fun though
has he ever had an incident from giving
his uh address out because i know it
just gives it out he doesn't do that
anymore not anymore okay but it's still
out there yeah people find their way
down there too many people just start
showing up at the super bowl parties and
[ __ ] i tried to tell them i'm like don't
do that
yeah i thought it was cute
you don't want people showing up in your
[ __ ] house especially
no no no but doug really likes chaos he
enjoys those chaotic situations he
really does when i looked at doug he had
a bunk bed i lived on the bottom big run
lived on the top
i had to stay with doug for like six
weeks it was [ __ ] craziness he
doesn't eat he just drinks coffee and
smoked cigarettes every month he's
quitting he's been quitting cigarettes
for how long now yeah he's not gonna
quit you know he don't give a [ __ ] he's
well he does give a [ __ ] but he doesn't
wanna
he's done he's quit for a few times he
has quit a few times
but he just gets back to it
it's a weird one man you you were caught
by that grip yeah but you could get off
it
once you it's tough but once you get up
but it's funny how he never really gave
his [ __ ]
like he picked up left he shows up with
a guy that's a manager he met him at a
sports lounge in tupelo mississippi
you know what i'm saying like that he
you know he he had like big time
management and that's done yeah he does
all his bookings himself
he hooked up with this lunatic that got
him the dvd
the cd what's his name you know pirates
of the caribbean oh yeah that's his
[ __ ] body you know johnny depp doug
really is
like in the air of lenny bruce like doug
is just crazy he's out there
you know he's legit he's legit that's
the way it is yeah that's the way it is
i was watching this special when it
first came out i'm sitting there going
how many years do i know this guy and he
stuck to the script but yeah this was
not if anything he got [ __ ] crazy
if anything he went deeper yeah like
i've known him since 91 he was a good
looking dude with a haircut i got a
picture of him yeah and then he [ __ ]
uh went on the the evening at the improv
and then he started headlining then he
won san francisco and he was buck wild
he was just destroying hollywood
yeah yeah
they would put them up at the store at
[ __ ] uh
doug stanhope with a mullet oh my god in
the pool up to his chest that's in vegas
with a glass of wine i don't even know
some sort of drink that's a [ __ ]
vegas i'm gonna put this i'll put this
on instagram later i i keep this close
and dear to my heart
where did you take that picture somebody
sent it to you no it was uh on the wall
at the store
really yeah yeah they have it at the
store it's like one of those super old
head shots that they they've stowed away
there that was his headshot still
remember that that was his head shot i
still have a picture at the broker that
was it
that was probably doug when he was 20
years old
tonight all those triple runs well he
probably wasn't even headlining back
then no he wasn't headlining back then i
met him he was featured at the triple
run everybody had to try some wacky
thing when you were taking your photo
try to stand out
you know i had a neck cream my first
headshot had an ice cream in my head
yeah
some guy took it behind the [ __ ] hey
bose pizza in boulder uh some dude kept
telling me i'm a photographer let me
take your headshot i go hurry up he goes
well what do you want like i don't know
i'm drinking this and he just took
pictures
and that was my first headshot
have you take one with a mustache
mustache listen
when he [ __ ] whatever kid from
[ __ ] hershey's he just said stand
behind the light he took two pics and
that was my headshot wow
what was your first headshot
jeff t took it
in boston jeff t the stand-up comedian
who wound up marrying that chick that's
on the view what's her name the one
who's really religious
the black girl in the view god damn it
why isn't it jerry sheppard sherry
shepard who's always at the store
remember sherry sheppard from the store
yeah before she was on the view she was
a comic she was always hanging at the
store she always had a clean set always
like very clean
very nice sherry shepherd is very so who
am i
my friend jeff t from boston really yeah
that was bad i think they got divorced
but uh they were married way back in the
disney but jeff was an amateur
photographer
and jeff um he took my first head shot
so stupid looking me with a leather
jacket on looking like an [ __ ] i took
another one afterwards with me looking
like an [ __ ] i've took several
headshots douchey when i was like 22.
you don't want to find those things it's
so [ __ ] so mad
they're so bad i had like a a tank top
on with like a leather motorcycle jacket
and i was looking sultry she just went
to war with her ex-husband over a kid
she had the eggs probably jeff
and he gave her the eggs and he bought
the eggs well it's her eggs
everybody's crazy joey isn't everybody
crazy i'm not like that but everybody's
a little crazy oh please we're all crazy
i still hear voices but i i'm [ __ ]
maintained brother
the craziness is what god has hit you
yeah
nobody's saying would do this nobody
people would back out of this after five
months and go one of my [ __ ] crazy we
should do a tour like like a real tour
figure out like who's gonna be on it do
like four of us ari i'm sure he's onto
his own thing right now he's probably uh
oh he's probably looking i bet you could
barely talk to him right now you're
probably learning new languages and [ __ ]
always that dude that got caught with
hash
in that movie midnight express he's
somewhere talking he jumps off in his
wife's tits when she comes to visit him
at the end but no he's somewhere
learning a culture
enjoying himself enjoying himself but
but putting together something like that
maybe segura wants to hop in maybe you
me maybe hitchcliff
just figure it we'll figure it out with
just a bunch of people yeah who's ever
available yeah and and just have some
fun because like one of the things that
i was thinking when we were doing those
shows in buffalo is like how much fun
we're having
hanging out doing these
just amazing shows
they're so fun
you know like whenever we're at the
store and we're hanging out doing each
i'm like this is these are amazing
nights they're so
it's so enjoyable and
it jazzes me up like it gets me pumped
up about comedy you know it gets me
excited to do more of it not that i'm
never i'm always excited about it but
even more so you know
you think it would happen with like
kings of comedy or the blue collar
comedy tour
or you know any of those things those
those
groups of guys that get together and put
together a show they're doing it now
still who's doing that eddie griffin
george look yes the black and brown
blue hoogly who else felipe is on the
door right now
isn't that too i'm not a different one
with uh oh he's with eddie apps and
those guys know he's with my gaps right
he's got a [ __ ] kangaroo yeah he got
my guy she had trouble with the kangaroo
did you see that yeah mike epps had a
kangaroo on stage i don't know what was
going on but he had a kangaroo
that is such that is such a funny
caption tommy ward we're at war tommy
warden thomas ward remember somebody
yeah
with mike absolutely they punched him in
the face at the store and then he caught
him somewhere and knocked him out
somewhere mike has been in war with um a
couple guys he got in war with cat
williams he got in war with um
kevin hart
kevin hart was the most hilarious guy
you got to bring your ticket sales up
if you want to go to war with me you got
to bring the ticket sales off i know you
want to compare yourself to me you're
doing some small colleges you're doing
some clubs a little small theater
it's like you bring your ticket tails up
the way he does it's like
so ruthless because he can't say
anything i mean he's he's kevin hart is
so energetic like in the way he like if
he's attacking you it's most likely
because you are attacked him it's like
this is a comeback that he couldn't
address him so you got to bring your
ticket sales up first
that's such a black comedian thing too
like if a white comedian talks like that
can you get crucified
you know
we were talking about this what the [ __ ]
happened to cat williams
he's got a special that's coming up
really yeah where's your 117 i saw it
the other day right after we talked
about that
he looks like he gained some weight dude
kev williams this day has some of my
favorite specials ever the pimp
chronicles
part one was amazing
was amazing the michael jackson thing
was amazing there was a couple of things
that were really [ __ ] amazing i still
remember doing his room up here for 50
bucks bro you did his room yeah right
here 10 years ago he came up to me to
the store when he was cat in the hat
oh that's right he was cat and a hat for
a while remember we used to hang sunday
nights
and one night he came up to me man that
was funny [ __ ] can you do my room right
here it's still there it's still like a
jazz club right before jerry's deli
if you hit jerry's deli in studio city
you went too far it's a block before all
that [ __ ] starts it's still there wow i
did it twice once with him and some once
with somebody else
and it was like 10 people he gave me 40
bucks he got dawg
i was happy as [ __ ]
and then 10 years later he shows up as
cat williams
[ __ ] killing [ __ ] he did
that special didn't he bring a lion on
stage didn't he have a lion in a cage
i wouldn't say he he had a he had a
wardrobe change in the middle of a
special in the middle of his bed he was
sweating so much because he's you know
he's always yelling and screaming and
jumping around saying he was setting so
much he took his [ __ ] clothes off he
went backstage and changed his clothes
i'm pretty sure he had a lion
i'm pretty sure
he had a lion did cat williams have a
lion on stage see if you can find that
i'm trying to find uh
i don't think so
that's the way to do it though maybe why
do i feel like he had a lion i feel like
he had a lion a lion or a tiger there's
a [ __ ] difference the the lion the
tiger one of us finally williams had a
lion on stage google that
you got it
i know i don't think so
yeah i googled it in two minutes you
have it
hilarious priceless special debut
kent williams stomped and jumped in the
head at philly concert
he's done some [ __ ]
he took some beatings doug he got into
fights at places
he's getting sued that one show
[ __ ] whatever live nation he killed
life nation life nation and they give
all the money back at the sacramento
what happened he did a show and then
didn't do stand up right yelled at some
people and then got off stage
he did something he was going through a
[ __ ] ton of [ __ ] you know i i laugh
at those stories like they say that
what's the girl's name killing me the
fuji's did i really yeah lauren hill
lauren hill gets to concerts
three hours late
like can you imagine getting to a
concert at 7 30 the show's supposed to
start at eight
and she don't go on until 10 30. are you
[ __ ] crazy
are you [ __ ] crazy
that's when you're just crazy well she
wasn't paying taxes they put her in the
pokey
that's one of the things they do with
taxes that they don't do with anything
else they put you in jail like if you
owe money like you say if you owe like
for a car that you didn't pay well you
you you know they get a lien on your
your funds and they wind up getting you
in jail but if you owe the government
money and you just don't pay taxes they
put you in a cage
and they don't [ __ ] around they even put
blade in the cage they put them in a
cage for a few years
they don't [ __ ] around it doesn't
discriminate bro
you all want look at they're gonna sell
your boy to school they're gonna send
him for [ __ ] 10 years
the kid from the jersey shore who
who's that the the situation oh they're
putting him in jail oh yeah for what
he's got two charges
what was the other one taxes or what i
thought it was payroll but let me check
are you high enough that you could
actually type i mean are you like sobra
see i have no idea he's just looking at
his eyes
i mean while he's typing him like
there's no way that guy could see that
screen he's a soldier at that he's he's
bro we got him trained just in case isis
takes over with thc
his levels are high and he can make it
what do you got there
put it up on the screen okay well i was
too high i could do it i just i didn't i
didn't know you wanted to know about the
dude no i want you to [ __ ] read i
want you to read it to me
[Music]
jersey shore star mike the situation
sorrentino hit with serious new tax
charges oh boy 8.9 million you're going
to
jail he dodge taxes from 2010 to 2012 on
8.9 million in income from promotional
events
he evaded payment by filing false
returns and by claiming millions in
business expenses including pricey cars
and personal grooming according the
first indictment new charges accuse the
situation of structuring funds to evade
currency transaction reports according
to a statement from the u s attorney's
office
in new jersey his brother is charged
with falsifying records to obstruct a
grand jury investigation if convicted on
all charges the brothers could face
29 oh my god 20 years in prison oh my
god
wow he's going away
um
yeah
tried to do some neighborhood [ __ ]
they tried to go old school with their
taxes
yeah see you on the side at one point he
made several cash deposits on the same
day
in several banks in the amount of less
than ten thousand dollars
to allegedly evade the bank's irs
reporting requirements
the brothers are scheduled to be
arraigned april 17.
now they don't owe 8.9 million
well depending on what his bracket is if
that's his bracket and he doesn't have
any deductions if they don't accept his
deductions wouldn't it be more than that
i don't know how that works oh no i
think i think it's three million and
then deductions stated gross receipts
claim fraudulent business deductions
see and once they catch you doing the
[ __ ] like let's say some people just
go listen i didn't know
yeah
i didn't know we'll tell you i'll tell
you what you don't know
you're gonna what do you got in the bank
oh i got about 600 000 okay
that goes to us no i get into three
years probation that's how said
something no no no you go to jail if you
pay it back no way if you pay back i had
a friend that no no no no blade tried to
pay it back
they're like you're going to jail
but there's a like how much did blade
take he didn't pay taxes he didn't pay
taxes he hooked up with one of those
wacky constitution dudes that was like
it says here on page 17 paragraph three
that'll shout not you know i mean they
have these crazy like tax low laws like
when you look at the tax code and you go
okay what is legal what's not legal and
what's the interest doesn't matter if
everybody else is paying taxes you have
to pay taxes yeah just because like it's
not written correctly somewhere like in
some way you think that you could evade
this on a technicality
they showed him what they wanted to show
they showed him by putting him in jail
they wanted to send a message that if
you do this even if you're famous will
lock you in a cage
that's what they do it's it's harsh
harsh business they
this this is hard to read because this
is when they see them when they know
you're trying to [ __ ] with them
that's when you get their [ __ ] that's
when you get their attention and a lot
of money nine million
like i said uh
what's that expression uh ignorance is
bliss yeah if you say you're stupid
that's one thing but if they catch you
trying to be tricky
that's when they [ __ ] find you
because there comes a fine too
restitution yeah the probation ain't
over till you pay you do know that right
well these guys i think they're slick
like this is like a all you have to do
you make several cash deposits on the
same day in several bank accounts as
long as they're under ten thousand
dollars the irs doesn't know [ __ ]
are you sure mikey you sure we could do
this this is what we do
we're not gonna [ __ ] pay them we're
gonna [ __ ] pay them all this money
you want to give a million dollars away
you want to take a
chance 20 years dude do you imagine what
that must feel like
well he's not going to get 20 he'll
probably get like [ __ ] three
and he'll have to do three and then
he'll have to he could ride horses
because he's not
take you a criminal
park you ride horses you learn how to
shoot bow and arrows
you draw pictures
everybody winds up going to jail too man
like those people from uh jersey
housewives housewives of new jersey the
guy and the girl the the husband i think
he went oh the girl went away first and
then the husband goes away second
something like that they've each got to
do a year
so i have to stay with the kid yeah it's
just and it's the same thing it's a tax
thing
i couldn't think about that now right
now taxes are scary that's the first
thing i [ __ ] do i don't play with
these people i can't we were murdered
for years they sent me a wrong amount
one time i cashed it i don't know
nothing it was too long ago forgive them
forget
they only go back seven years
well now that you talked about it you're
definitely gonna get away with it yeah
it was two hundred dollars what did i
give a [ __ ] i was supposed to get 59
no i'll tell you what it was they sent
me two tax returns the same check like
they [ __ ] up yeah the computer had
[ __ ] up so they sent the check on
saturday and one on monday the same
exact check
i cashed them both i took what chance
columbus did
[ __ ] business law if something lands
in your mailbox is yours nine tenths of
possessions
i love you brother i love you very much
for coming i'm having a lot of fun and i
love the fact that people love this
podcast your podcast is huge you know we
have people up to me all the time we
talk we just talk normal here there's no
[ __ ] drama
i'll give the shout outs late and all
that [ __ ] levity live 420
and 427 i'll be at the temblor brewing
company in bakersfield i'm gonna go up
there spend the day with matt baker and
learn how to choke people correctly
from the fat man side control he taught
me
then i got utah and then i'm in uh
milwaukee are you dealing with guys
[ __ ] yeah yeah i'm doing wise guys we're
doing wise guys in july i'll be there
may
5th and 6th very nice you land on friday
morning i love that club i love it i
love that city i love that
salt lake city one of the most
underrated cities in the country people
have a weird assessment of it but
they're real nice people
the [ __ ] shows are fun and not
everybody's a mormon no there's a lot of
non-mormons there's good weed there's a
part of the other the best olive garden
in the country the busiest olive garden
in the country
is in salt lake city they walk in there
they think it's [ __ ] uh spark
steakhouse i'm a big fan of utah people
i like utah
i like those people you ski updates yeah
sometimes i've never been up there to
ski you know what though
aspen to me you can't [ __ ] with it you
know why because the way it looks like
when you look aspen is so [ __ ]
beautiful when you're up there you're
like
like how could it like you if you went
to park city
or um yeah that's where it is right
where they ski
you look around there gorgeous right
beautiful i mean it's amazing looking
but aspen's somehow another top set it
takes it to another level well you look
you look at aspen you go i don't believe
it it got more beautiful like it's just
one
notch more wooded one notch more rivers
and streams one notch more beautiful
like those mountain towns man
that's what's up like that's that's
living man those super rich dudes have
figured out a way to move to aspen and
they're up there with the range rovers
every other [ __ ] car is up there's a
range rover the stops still have the
cops still have sobs i don't know that's
funny dude that's what they used to ask
me that's no mess they should have
subarus
it's uh it's a different way of living
if i could figure out how to live there
i would try to figure do you think you
could just one day just
go out of there and do the podcast
just do the podcast live and because i
know you're talking about going to
colorado i talk about going a lot of
places i just don't know what i would do
i would have leave to teach me how to do
the podcast not with zoe ruins from a
cabin
you know where
you would really have to consider it we
would all have to consider it if valley
gets hit with a quake
some real [ __ ] goes down in l.a
you really have to take into
consideration that we're just pretending
that that can't happen listen man
i told you what my fear was in l.a i'm
not worried about a [ __ ] earthquake
right we became a sanctuary state
that means if something happens we get
into zero [ __ ] funding that means if
there is a [ __ ] major earthquake
instead of taking two days for supplies
to get help from the federal government
will take 10 days maybe well when did we
become a sanctuary last week why because
that's the way life is that's the way
life works itself out and that's been
starting to scare me a little bit how
did that distinction change because they
hold back federal funding
they [ __ ] around with your paper
well they're they're threatening to do
that i don't think
because they're saying if they have
people he's got a google machine right
in front of you son oh yeah [ __ ] around
find out what it is i don't think it's a
threat that they were i think that
retaliated at some [ __ ] level
i go down to hollywood and i see the
weed stores
and i could see [ __ ] trump coming in
here and shutting down ten of them on
sunset strip you know they're getting
too [ __ ] lacks
so now you we just legalize marijuana
now you want to become a sanctuary state
you know what's interesting there's a
story today on one of the news sites
about how many pot arrests they have in
washington dc
even though marijuana is legal now in
washington dc they still arrest people
for pot and it's primarily african
americans
oh please primarily black dudes getting
arrested for weed in a place where weeds
legal
they do what they want your brother
always remember it's a federal [ __ ]
law we're just living on rented borrowed
time i i appreciate that courage
i appreciate that they're trying to do a
[ __ ] thing but when i went to
hollywood a month ago and i got stuck in
holly when i was driving on santa monica
what i saw on la brea
and the the [ __ ] billboards i was
like
wow
listen i don't mind you're a gangster
just don't remind me i don't mind if
you're a gangster just don't remind me
keep it small
there's one that you pull up to at the
light by target on the bread
that you look at and go
like a [ __ ] amusement store my friend
looks like somebody saying 20 million
into it
so i know that the investments are high
but i don't think they covered
themselves before they dotted the teas
and that's what scares me that that's
the only way trump could re that's one
of the ways he could really [ __ ] with us
if we become a sanctuary of state
colorado colorado ain't becoming no
sanctuary i don't know that sanctuary
state but colorado got their weed game
so tight
they could send [ __ ] the dea in there
and you can't [ __ ] with colorado
colorado would come up with you know all
these states that where you go now they
have a whole floor now to marijuana
where it was just one attorney you know
what i'm saying like if your attorney
office has seven floors they had one
office about marijuana now they have two
floors the thing is it's still a federal
issue it's a federal issue and that's
why i don't like what i see yeah well
you got a good
good point i mean that jeff sessions guy
that they have now he's scary in a lot
of ways like he's publicly said that
good people don't smoke marijuana
maybe he believes that he might believe
that but maybe he's been influenced by
companies that would benefit from
keeping marijuana illegal or reversing
the trend
that's possible too you know there's a
lot of people that think that there's
medical pharmaceutical companies rather
that stand to lose millions and millions
of dollars from this
but they absolutely will maybe even
billions they already proved that
all the states that have legalized
marijuana
uh opioid emergency room visits it down
colorado is a sanctuary state is it yeah
and then what they're saying is i mean
he
obviously he could probably make things
difficult but what about california
legally california is but you said
colorado colorado do you mean california
no i meant con well i meant
we knew california was
joey asked if colorado was so california
definitely is yes so that and that's
last week it changed over yeah and i
mean
it's [ __ ] up but yeah i mean they can
[ __ ] it they can [ __ ] themselves like
the [ __ ] with your dog well here's the
thing here's how you mitigate that right
like how much how much funds are we
talking about and would there be a way
to make a fund to make up for it if it's
because of marijuana
you could tax marijuana 39 percent
nobody gives a [ __ ] probably gives a
[ __ ] it's still cheap you can do it and
if you do do that you know how much
money the state generates and that
probably takes care of emergency
services
like if you if you thought about 24 7
marijuana sales in california and 24 7
taxes coming in and high taxes no one
would care and you just take all that
money because that's what they have in
colorado like medical it's one
percentage
but then if it's recreational i think
it's somewhere in the neighborhood of 40
or 39 or something like that you could
do that and then that would be
hundreds of millions of dollars and
that's the money you use to take care of
yourself if some [ __ ] goes down you're
probably more than you're gonna get from
the federal government anyway well and
then the last year this is what i heard
that they had tax returns for like
weed like they made so much money that
some people got tax returns or all the
residents
yeah they made so much money in taxes
that people got checks
and like you were just saying could that
could there be a fund maryland just
voted that if planned parenthood gets
defunded they'll fund planned parenthood
yeah well there you go
yeah i mean if if you get enough people
that can generate enough money from
something that's easy like growing
marijuana not easy but it can be done
it's not like making cell phones over in
china you don't need a factory with nets
around to keep people from jumping off
the roof if you want to grow pot it's
not that hard
and if you did that and you just had
listen everybody's going to make a
shitload of money anyway it's like it's
not about having a hundred million
dollars it's about not being broke
you're not making plenty of money so you
make plenty of money and you live in an
amazing community where everything gets
taken care of school gets taken care of
teachers get paid more money doctors get
paid everybody gets paid and there's
plenty of money why because you let
people grow a plant
and nobody's dying of overdoses the
overdose deaths drop drastically
dropping cancer visits all these people
with health issues that are worried
about cbd oils all that's that's easy to
get hemp oil
you deal with a lot of people
alleviating pain and disease
and you make a shitload of money it's a
win-win it's just not a win-win for the
pharmaceutical companies so when a guy
comes in and he's saying that this is
something we need to target you've got
to go well why not it's not logical if
you look at the issues that people are
developing from pain pill addiction you
look at how many people have overdosed
just on that fentanyl stuff that's the
stuff that killed um
um that's the stuff that killed uh
michael jackson no prince
michael jackson we were talking about
that you get what set it up fentanyl
it's a super potent opiate
super potent like many many times
stronger than oxycontin's so it's really
easy to overdose there's a mma fighter
josh the man
he um he overdosed from it too
apparently i heard i don't know if that
was i'm pretty sure that was it that's
what it kind of should have said that
because i'm not exactly sure but
somebody um told me that
and then um
i think there's been there's been quite
a few deaths from that stuff a fentanyl
stuff's very scary and so there's that
that's legal and this you don't see this
guy chasing that down saying hey folks
there's an herbal remedy it's called
edible marijuana it's probably as
effective as anything you're talking
about and it doesn't kill a goddamn
single person
like
and you can grow it yourself
you know you can make your own and
communities can make their own i mean it
wouldn't be hard at all to make it dirt
cheap
it's a weed for christ's sake it's super
hardy you don't need very many
pesticides what do you need you need
fertilizer and light good soil good soil
and water and you have one of the most
profitable plants known to man you have
the gold crop
and so the the
boundary to entry
it's not that difficult it's not that
difficult to get in the game
you know i'm talking about lisa i
i do do they have i was wondering if
they had medical marijuana or
recreational in aspen and like in nicer
communities
um they haven't surrounding communities
i saw it in colorado it was funny we
were we were driving to this place to go
uh race uh
um not jet skis snowmobiles
snowmobile racing with the kids
[ __ ] hilarious it's so fun they have
a track
and they take you out and they take you
on a tour through the mountains and you
come back and you race snowmobiles it's
fun man we had a good time as long as
you don't get silly you know don't wipe
out and if you do you wipe it out in
fluffy snow anyway
but uh we passed this place in this
really nice like small town like pretty
nice houses and apparently like wealthy
people have their estates out there and
there's a weed stop just big big old
[ __ ] weed stop
just come on in buy some weed you just
got to show a driver's license my mom
bought wheat in boulder
this last time yeah yeah my stepdad had
to stay in the car because he didn't
bring his driver's license he wouldn't
let him in
is that the first time or was it the
opposite maybe he got it my mom didn't
ever license they wouldn't let her in
was that the first time your mom bought
weeds she just i think so yeah the first
time she's ever bought it from
like a place like that cool was that to
walk in the store for their lifetime it
freaks me out i can't imagine well they
were hippies yeah they were in 70s like
they'd never dreamed of that they were
like it's not going to happen we gave up
on that [ __ ] 20 years ago nobody
understood it they were like why
like how how is it still illegal i mean
think about it it was illegal joey in
1970 right
so
when i was three it was illegal it
became legal when i was 49.
who would have thought that
with all the evidence not a single
person died in all that time
not a single person died of an overdose
i mean people probably did stupid [ __ ]
when they were high
but people do stupid [ __ ] i never
thought i would walk into a store and
buy marijuana
how about getting it delivered how about
speed weed how about places like that
talk to people they show up with weed
what do you need this i don't like to
deliver it to myself you don't have to
go to the house i get to deliver to the
store
what store comedy store oh no no i know
but no or i need them at el compadres i
like the experience of going in and
seeing the wheat i'm about to get i want
a professional no no i don't want no
games i don't like surprises
i'm not much for surprise parties i know
what i want
i gotta see the person who's selling it
to me yeah they have a connection with
them uh where i go perennial i know two
of the girls there's one girl from st
louis that knows i want to smoke that's
him this is a check uh from a chinese
girl
that knows what i smoke and that the
place over here there's a little
girl that looks like she's little butts
she really does like she's a runaway
dog when i she sees me walking in there
she knows exactly what i want and they
have blood tenders and you tip them
right yeah you look like a tip jar throw
some money in there yeah young girls i
always put [ __ ] 10 out of 20 and then
three figure eight girls man
you know when they get like 10 bucks an
hour when they chop up the tips now when
you're going in now
do you go and you just have to present
your driver's license yeah you don't
have to have a license for marijuana no
i still got my i still got my license i
gotta have it they haven't straightened
that out yet that's why we're behind
don't don't that's why people really
that's why it's not like
right no no they're not going to get
that [ __ ] together to 2 18.
so anything can happen it's like the way
it's like wednesdays on the mickey mouse
club dog anything could happen today oh
you remember angel heart you might have
saw angel yeah yeah yeah did you see it
yeah after i said it yeah i knew well i
i i remember that line
yeah yeah it's wednesday it's wednesday
night thank you can happen today what
are you saying to me um [ __ ] jesus lee
yeah
they're going to do this i'm like oh
this guy
why is he i could have sworn kat
williams had a [ __ ] lion on stage no
i can't believe that that might have
been a really good dream yeah it must
have been i got i was that was one of
the ones i was always convinced
cat williams tiger on stage let's try
that t-i-g-e-r
how are you in the future you [ __ ]
yeah that's so ridiculous
but you you made a good point though no
he did i get it too i always thought too
i always thought that
i liked the idea of the podcast because
it reminded me of being young
and listening to albums that were dirty
and i had to hide him i had to listen to
him on the on the slide
that's why i really was curious with the
podcast
because i wanted americans to listen
again yeah i really believe in listening
we don't listen
we do not [ __ ] listen you know
well there's definitely more people
listening to conversations like this
like these long conversations like you
do on your podcast and duncan does on
his and i do and a lot a lot of people
do these like that there's more people
doing this now than
i just don't i don't think anybody's
ever had anything like this this often
before that's so raw
you know you have howard stern of course
but there was always we'll be right back
cut into commercial and he's always
arguing with the network about this and
you know the fcc find them i mean he he
broke down all the doors
like if it wasn't for him if it wasn't
for him and you know he got sued dude
the government sued him
for just talking about certain [ __ ]
certain subject matter
but [ __ ] crazy but still that you had
to have a radio station you had to have
a business you had to be the the main
guy competing in the business today
anybody listening to this anybody listen
to this can start a podcast
and if they do it for long enough and
they work at it hard enough and if it's
good enough and two people tell two
people tell two people and then
everybody knows about it and it
literally by word of mouth
there's a lot of p and people say oh
that's easy for you so you've broken
already established that is the voice of
doom and doubt creeping your [ __ ]
head you gotta listen there's people
today that can come up with a podcast
and it can still hit look at those two
girl two guys we [ __ ] you know those
girls
you know they have that podcast guys we
[ __ ] yeah podcast is killing it it's
always top ten always they're killing it
they sold out the main room at the store
like that
they know those those aren't famous
girls they probably are now but the
girls who invented that show they were
just a couple female comedians wanted to
put together a podcast they came up with
a funny
name for it and it became huge
anybody could do that that's totally
doable now especially with itunes has a
very reasonable and generous algorithm
like the the algorithm that they use to
rank your show
like if your show your show's been
around for years right and you get a
shitload of downloads if some new person
comes along they could have a fraction
of the downloads that you do but they'll
be right next to you in the rankings
because it's new so they get an
allotment for new shows so that keeps
the
the top 10 on top 20 and top you know
top 50 whatever fresh you get you get
new shows coming in all the time and
when you have stuff like that like it
makes it possible it's possible all it
has to do is like you know you have
someone on say if you at ian and ian has
a new podcast and you tell everybody
check out ian edwards podcast you know
it's called the duh and then people
listen to this go that guy was great let
me check it out and then they go i mean
that's what we've done yeah that's what
we've done
how did we do that i mean we all of us
have hit podcasts and we all we all just
did it together i see the people who
deviate and start a podcast
and think they want to join this product
i stepped with this this is what i
wanted to do from day one i already had
a plan and i stuck with it yeah but your
studio you need to listen
i want people to listen
i'm sick and [ __ ] tired of people not
[ __ ] listening
i grew up where you had a [ __ ] listen
people they don't [ __ ] listen i get
it with the [ __ ] text messages and
with the [ __ ] you don't listen like
i told somebody at the store don't text
me the first thing he did was text me
they don't listen you know and i was
raised with the [ __ ] old
interview sheets remember when you
applied for a job in the 70s it said
five lines your name address then there
was a box and it said don't answer the
[ __ ] questions unless there's a check
in that [ __ ] box
and my friend thought i was at a
sandwich place one time
and i go you need help man hi somebody
goes look at all the people who applied
already i can't hide none of these
dummies
because they all [ __ ] wrote in here
that says don't
so if they can't get that right yeah i
don't want to do business with them when
people don't listen i don't want to do
business with them like if i tell you
something an hour and two hours later
you call me with something stupid i just
don't meet you from the phone like i'm
i'm done like i'm [ __ ] done i can't
deal with so i wanted to make people
[ __ ] listen again
it's a great gift to have
i love to talk but i also love to
[ __ ] listen the other day when you
and dominic were talking 40 minutes and
i raised my [ __ ] hand
did i raise my [ __ ] hand
no i'm learning
i didn't have i wasn't in the place to
[ __ ] raise my hand i'm amongst people
who really know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about
that's a problem in america today people
want to chime in when they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about you
think i went to jiu jitsu because i like
smelling [ __ ] and feet and you think
i like choking definitely it's not in my
itinerary but you know what man i'm sick
and tired of listening to mma [ __ ]
analysts that never even tackled the
[ __ ] tackle dummy
how are you gonna know what this guy is
feeling in the ring if you never got
clocked in the face do me a favor shut
the [ __ ] up that's with any sports
writer they they sit there and they
insult football players when the last
time you play football [ __ ] all you know
what they're doing out there now no you
know what happens with basketball it
happens with baseball there's always
these people that you look at them and
they've never done nothing in their
[ __ ] life and they want to write
about a sport they don't know oh i was a
fan of the game no you were a fan but
you never played it do you know anik
started taking jiu jitsu you have to
from you have to
yeah me just [ __ ] around with you
guys
i have to do something i have to
describe a hip escape i have to know
what it's like before i can sit there
and judge a guy right where the [ __ ] am
i but that goes on a lot in today let me
start up a blog because you know and i'm
talking bad about michael's biz being
not fighting whatever what the [ __ ] did
you do what the [ __ ] did you do but you
do a lot of it is them just trying to
get attention and the way to get
attention is to be negative and i've
been very vocal fighting against that i
don't like insulting writers that that
[ __ ] on mma in particular don't like it
because at any level it's not they're
not respecting what that thing is that
thing is an insanely difficult endeavor
to be a fighter and to put your emotions
on the line and then for someone to
callously disregard that look you can
pump up the person who won and you could
criticize the technique of the person
who lost but they go way further than
that there's some of them that they they
make a person look like a buffoon i
don't like that [ __ ] there's no reason
for that we learned a lot with ronda
rousey we learned a lot about society
there's two things that taught me a lot
the last year when ronda rousey got
knocked out and when [ __ ] trump won
and that [ __ ] mutt went to his house
for dinner to try to interview for the
job after he badmouthed him that's
christine
no no not the fat [ __ ] thing
when rick romney managed to find trump
and then trump won he went to his house
and you know why people didn't say
nothing about it because people do it
all the time they're just snakes they're
disgusting
we've become disgusting people you know
so that's why nobody ever said wait a
second that guy's a [ __ ] mutt he'll
never get he should be banned like
united
you you talked about trump i mean you
went out and blasted him not just saying
speech yeah pre-read speech and now
you're going to his house to try to get
a job you should be shot and hung he
rehearsed that [ __ ] yeah but americans
didn't see it they just let it go that's
why lee's right you know what we all see
this thing with united i don't [ __ ]
unite it's always my third choice
united is my fourth choice
okay it's american i go to delta i go to
jet blue i try uh virgin but they don't
fly everywhere they go to austin you got
to go to san francisco first i ain't got
that type of time so the only time i
could use them is to go to [ __ ] new
york that's the only use i got out of
virginia they're great in new york but
united i look at every once in a while
like i'm like
should i take the chance every once in a
while they come through with like a
short flight it's an hour and a half you
catch your night you don't really want
to go on southwest but you know what
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i don't like you [ __ ]
anyway you can't wear your yoga pants
[ __ ] i gotta help you guys with this
sound
i know you guys figure this out yeah you
need a uh you need a whole board that
takes this then um
something's been going on with pops
but don't tell them compression don't
tell them because then they all become
sound designs
i'll hook you up with jamie yeah we'll
figure this out i love you i love you
too brother i love you thanks for
everything thank you thanks for this
weekend
tremendous we got to eat those wings
that was great [ __ ] around none of these
[ __ ] west coast wings with rants suck
my dick i love you guys
levity live 420 temblor i love you
[ __ ] have a great night great
week thank you this podcast is brought
to you by i hate my boss the newest
podcast from wondering need workplace
advice
go listen to i hate my boss and
subscribe to it wherever you're
listening to this podcast
have you ever worked for a boss who
can't make up his mind then blames you
for it it's frustrating and you're not
alone who do you talk to about that
where do you get workplace advice
where can you say those four words i
hate my boss well i'll tell you where
there's a new podcast called i hate my
boss with two workplace heroes help you
make the big decisions sort through the
small stuff and get more fulfillment
from your workplace it's about people
who go to work who are part of a team
who respect their bosses sometimes and
who need to escape you also meet some
characters that you might relate to or
know and we'll help you deal with them
new episodes of i hate my boss drop
every monday just in time for your work
week
i saw the trailer and it's fantastic
okay go listen
to i hate my boss and subscribe to it
wherever you listen to podcast i hate my
boss workplace drama comedic relief
subscribe today i hate my boss
it's a pretty good little show it's a
tremendous little show go listen to it
take a chance columbus did you're going
to love it if you like uncle joey you'll
like this show
what do you do when you want to snack
what all you can find is junk food rely
on your self-control to resist the
temptation please you eat that junk food
like anybody else start snacking healthy
with nature box nature box makes snacks
that actually taste good and a great and
a better for you created with high
quality ingredients that are free form
artificial colors flavors or sweetness
so you can feel great about snacking
my personal favorites are the cocoa buns
and what else you i like
i like the salt and pepper cashews i
like the salt and pepper uh lentils
lentils and the chocolate nom noms are
good tremendous
naturebox recently made their service
even better now you can order as much as
you want as often as you want with no
minimum purchase required and you can
cancel at any time it's simple go to
naturebox.com and check out the snack
catalog the there are over 100 snacks to
choose from and they're constantly
adding delicious new snacks choose the
snacks you want and they'll deliver them
listen to this right to your door
you can watch the 600 pound man and join
them
with nature box you'll never get bored
if they're new snacks each month
inspired by real customer feedback and
if you ever try a snack you don't like
nature box will replace it ready for
this for free
a snack you don't like you taste it you
send it back to replace it for free and
right now you'll save even more nature
box is offering our fans 50 off your
first order when you go to naturebox.com
joey again that's naturebox.com
joey for 50 off your first order let me
tell you something that's a tremendous
deal naturebox.com
joey start snacking healthy all right
bring the bag to work with you knock
yourself out all day you'll be fine you
go to the gym you'll lose a little
weight you it's bikini season cut this
[ __ ] number two what it's bikini season
you're gonna shave that monkey
you're gonna get a suntan
but then something happens and it starts
weekend or your muffler starts thinking
guess what we got a superman for you the
days are back [ __ ] the church of
what's happened now would like to
introduce hellotushy.com
portable bidets that spray your muffler
spotless or your monkey whatever you're
into or if you switch governments
whatever you're holding you know what
i'm saying it gets ugly down there from
time to time whatever you have you need
a little water down there hello she got
the answer for you
listen it's biological you don't use
toilet paper all right it's clean water
that comes right out let me tell you
something there's an electric shock how
you gonna wash your face with the bidet
all right you save on toilet paper
you're saving on trees you're a nice guy
you don't have to go buy a prius and
show your friends your half a fruit cake
and [ __ ] and they give a [ __ ] about the
environment with hello tushi you are
you're saving trees you're saving
[ __ ] jungles okay you're just
sprinkling water whether it's got
minerals in it or not you gotta get a
filter for the hello tushie if not your
[ __ ] will smell worse than it did
when you started the program that's a
joke go to hellotushy.com right now and
press in church and get 10 off your
order delivered to your house whatever
you need they got a 60-day money-back
guarantee but you're not gonna listen
you're gonna love it trust me take it
from a fat dude
mathematically can't wipe his ass from
time to time because my shoulders hurt
so listen hellotushy.com and get your
[ __ ] right that's that's the new
slogan hellotushy.com
get that [ __ ] smelling right i love
you [ __ ] with all my heart have
a great week thank you for listening
[Music]